FROM THE SENATE TO RESEARCH THE
WATER COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS O MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN RISK THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND IS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCES
PATIENT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE LINE THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE NOW ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBERS 877-226-8163 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT. THREE THREE. I
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
THING IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. FOR HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING I'LL ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
BE PRESENT NOW IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM. OF A WILL FOR NOW BE
BEGINNING AS A SUB COMMITTEE- SO
WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE FIRST
ITEM AND HERE BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE- FIRST UP IS S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE FROM SENATOR
GROW- WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL TEN
BIT WE HAVE. ADDITIONAL NINE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. ARE- ON
PER. JUST FOR EVERYONE'S
INFORMATION BUT- WE'LL START
WITH CENTER GROVE MORNING
MORNING GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS MY **** YES GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TODAY IMPRISONING SB ELEVEN
TWENTY FIVE WHICH CREATES A
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE PROGRAM
WITHIN CAL JIM TO PERMIT SMALL
INDEPENDENT OIL PRODUCERS TO
ESTABLISH PRIVATELY OWNED
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS TO COVER THE
COST OF PLUGGING IN- ABANDONING
. OIL WELLS IN LIEU OF
MAINTAINING A BOND CURRENTLY CAL
JIM REQUIRE SMALL INDEPENDENT
OIL OPERATORS TO BOND ON NEW
EXISTING WELLS FROM TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A WELL
THAT'S LESS THAN TEN THOUSAND
FEET AND FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR A WELL GREATER THAN TEN
THOUSAND FEET. CAL FOR BLAME.
HAVE RESULT WELLS ADDITIONALLY
CURRENT LAW GRANTS CAL JIM THE
AUTHORITY TO MANDATE AN
ADDITIONAL BOND AMOUNT ON TOP OF
THE BASE AMOUNT ON WELLS THAT
THEY DEEM AT RISK WHICH COULD
COST A SMALL INDEPENDENT OIL
PRODUCER UP TO THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS PER WELL. IF YOU ALSO
INCLUDE THE ASSESSED FEES AND
TAXES PRODUCERS PAY INTO
INCLUDING OIL AND GAS AND
GEOTHERMAL MINISTRY DEFEND AND
THE HAZARDOUS AND IDLE DESERTED
WELF AND ABANDONMENT FUND SMALL
INDEPENDENT OIL PRODUCERS ARE
LOOKING AT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
PAID OUT ON MONEY THAT THEY WILL
NEVER BE ABLE TO USE TO SHUT
DOWN IMPROPERLY ABANDON THEIR
WELLS. OIL PRODUCERS PLUG. WELLS
ALL THE TIME AT THE COST OF
DOING IN THE PAST OF DOING THIS
PLUGGING AND ABANDONING WELLS-
SOLELY REP REST ON THE PRODUCER.
I WITH THE EXCEPTION OF WHAT
HAPPENS THROUGH THE STATE
ADDITIONALLY INDUSTRY EXPERTS
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN THAT
INDEMNITY BONDS ARE GENERALLY-
COMMERCIALLY AND BILLABLE
PRODUCERS. CITING CURRENTS K.
DISK TRYS. BOB THAT FIGHTS
CHAIRS MOST NO FIND BENEFIT
ISSUING FUND. TO KNOWS IS THAT
WITH THE CHANGE THE DATE. INCOME
DOING IT CALIPHS. THESE SIRS. OF
A YOUR MOUTH. IT DOES THIS FOR
THIS BUSINESS TO. WE CANNOT ARE
WE PAINT NUMBER WITH A BROAD
BRUSH AND BRUSH AND OIL
PRODUCERS AND BECAUSE OF THEIR
LIABILITIES AND COSTS CAN VARY
WIDELY I MEAN ON THE LOCATION
DIGITALIZED GO PROFILE OF THE
POTENTIAL WELL AND OTHER ISSUES
EACH PRODUCED IN THE CIVIC
CENTER BESTED TO PLUG THEM WHEN
THEY WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT YOU
SHOULD ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIA WILL
SERVE. MANY RECENT EIGHTEEN ANTI
COMMISSION BILLS RATHER THAN
POLICIES THE HINDER COMPANY'S
ABILITY TO THRIVE. SB ELEVEN
TWENTY FIVE ALSO AIMS AT KEEPING
CALIFORNIA SMALL INDEPENDENT OIL
PRODUCERS IN BUSINESS AND
ACCOUNTABLE WHILE AFFORDING THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE THEIR OWN
FUNDS BUILT OVER TIME TO
RESPONSIBLE AND EFFICIENT
EFFICIENTLY. PLUG AND ABANDON
THEIR WELLS SB ELEVEN TWENTY
FIVE ACHIEVES THIS BY ALLOWING
SMALL INDEPENDENT OIL. TO
ESTABLISH A STEVENS ACCOUNT. THE
BONDING THAT THEY WOULD
CONTRIBUTE TO A RATE OF 5% OF
THEIR ANNUAL REVENUE. THIS
ACCOUNT WILL BE VERIFIED BY CAL
JAM THROUGH AN ANNUAL AUDIT IN
THE END OF ALL THIS ACCOUNT
INFORMATION MY FIRST WITNESS TO
TESTIFY BY PHONE TODAY ON A S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE IS MISTER
HOWARD K. HOOD. BELIEVES HE HE
IS A FORTUNE- SINCE INDEPENDENT
OIL OPERATOR WHERE HIS FAMILY
THE SMALL WELLS THAT THEY HAVE
THE SMALL MINIMUM OF WILL. OUR
JOB. INDIVIDUALS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE THEIR JOB THIS
FAMILY OPERATES A SMALL-NUMBER
OF WELLS THAT IS PROVIDED FOR
THEIR FAMILY OVER THE LAST FEW
AND FEW YEARS AGO ACTUALLY
GENERATIONS- MR KATE IS
AVAILABLE BY PHONE SIR. VERY
GOOD- SO WE'LL WE'LL TURN FIRST
TOWARD LEAD SPORT WITNESS HERE
ON THE PHONE MISTER K. WHAT. IF
YOU HERE WITH US MODERATOR FEW
COLLEAGUES PORT WITH. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S HOWARD K. WHAT
. GOOD MORNING SIR. YOU CAN
PROCEED WITH MORNING I'M- I'M
ACTUALLY A THIRD GENERATION
INDEPENDENT OIL PRODUCER OF. THE
AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN WOULD PUT ME
OUT OF BUSINESS. AS FAR AS
HAVING THE BOND ALL MY PRODUCING
WELLS. AND MY LIABILITY SO I
CAME UP WITH A SAVINGS TO CAL.
AND SO I WROTE THAT. BUILDER I
HAVE ALREADY SAVED ENOUGH TO
ABANDON ONE WHILE WITHIN TWO
MONTHS THREE MONTHS. I THINK I
THINK UNDER THE STATE'S RULING
OF AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN. HE
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE
PROTECTED YOU JUST END UP WITH A
BUNCH AN ORPHAN WELLS PEOPLE
JUST WALK AWAY FROM HOME.
REGARDLESS OF THE CONSEQUENCES
FOR THIS BILL. YOU HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE TO SAVE THE MONEY
AND ABANDONED THE WELLS. AS YOU
NEED TO. AND AT THE STATE FALLS
THROUGH WITH THE TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. THEN WE'D ALL HAVE ABOUT
TO MEET OUR LIABILITIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- I THINK WE HAVE
ONE MORE LEAD SUPPORT WHEN HIS
HEARING THE HEARING ROOM THREE
ONE TIME SURE STERN AND MEMBERS-
JOHN ONE TIME FOR THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WE APPRECIATE SENATOR GROW
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IS A
CRITICAL BILL HAS BEEN MENTIONED
AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN ALLOWED CAL JIM TO
REQUIRE BONDS OF UP TO THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL PRODUCER. OF AS OF
THIS SIZE SIMPLY ARE NOT
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE IN CAL.
THIS BILL WILL. BY WITH CURRENT
LAW COMPANIES ARE HAVING TROUBLE
FINDING BONDS EVEN IN THE ONE TO
TWO MILLION DOLLAR RANGE SAYS
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO GUARANTEE
THE BONDS IN PERPETUITY EVEN IF
THE PLICY OWNER GOES DEFUNCT OR
DOES NOT PAY THE PREMIUMS
INDEMNITY BONDS ARE ONLY
EXERCISE WHEN COMPANIES GO
COMPLETELY OUT OF BUSINESS IT'S
IN THE STATE'S BEST INTEREST FOR
OIL PRODUCERS TO STAY IN
BUSINESS AND CONTINUE TO PLUG
AND ABANDON THEIR OWN IDLE
WELLS. WITH THEIR OWN MONEY KEEP
IN MIND THAT THE IDYLLWILD
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM REQUIRES OIL
AND GAS PRODUCER'S TO PLUG AND
ABANDON 425% OF THEIR IDLE WELLS
EACH YEAR IN ORDER TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF AB TEN FIFTY
SEVEN PRODUCER SHOULD BE ALLOWED
TO SAVE CAPITAL INTO SECURED
FINANCIAL INSTRUMENTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THE ACTUAL
PLUGGING AN ABANDONED BAND
ANOTHER WELL. S. WHAT IT- IS
THIS FOR COMPANIES TO STAY BY.
IF THE PROBE ESTABLISHED IN AB
TWO SAID SIMPLY RELIES ON THE
INDEMNITY BONDS THAT ARE
COMMERCIALLY UNAVAILABLE IN AN
EFFORT TO PROTECT THE STATE
AGAINST THE POTENTIAL FINANCIAL
LIABILITY OF ORPHANED WELLS. THE
PROGRAM RISKS BECOMING A SELF
FULFILLING PROPHECY. COMPANIES
WILL BE FORCED OUT OF BUSINESS
SINCE THEY ARE UNABLE TO OBTAIN
THE BONDS REQUIRED AND- THEN
CLICK. CLOSE WHEN AB FIFTY SEVEN
WAS DEBATED MANY INSURANCE WERE
ASSURANCES WERE GIVEN. BY THE
AUTHOR ITS SUPPORTERS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THERE WOULD
BE FLEXIBILITY. THIS BILL
CREATES THE FLEXIBILITY AND
WOULD FULFILL THOSE PROMISES
ABOUT RESPECT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- NOW WE WILL TURN TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- JUST
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM
WAS TESTIFYING SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE WILL TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR WOULD
YOU- WOULD YOU MIGHT OPEN A
LIFE. SHOULD TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE. TO
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MAY
TWENTY SPECIALIST WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
WILL CALL YOUR LIFE WHEN YOU'RE
READY. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE DO
HAVE LINE'S QUEUING UP.
WE'RE STILL WITHIN THE Q. MISTER
MODERATED. YES JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBER OKAY. IT WILL OPEN
UP LINE ELEVEN YEAH. J. HARPER
ORDERED US YOUR FUTURE OF THAT
MEETING. WELL PLACE. OKAY MAYBE
IT IS THEN THAT ABBOTT WORKER I
LIVE IN THE CITY OF ORANGE AND I
SUPPORT SENATOR STERN BILL SB
ONE FOUR TWO THREE THAT WOULD
CLOSE THE BIG LOOPHOLE THAT HAS
ALLOWED THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY
TO EVADE FOR DECADES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BYE WITH IMPORTANT
PROTECTION THANKS A LOT OF
CALIFORNIA. I DO APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT FOR MY FOR MY
LEGISLATION BUT WE'RE ON A
DIFFERENT BILL BUT WE'RE YOUR
TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW IT'S ENOUGH
TO CALL BACK IN SO WILL. NOTE
THAT TESTAMENT TO APPRECIATE IT.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE WE'RE JUST
LOOKING FOR SUPPORT TESTIMONY ON
SB ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE WHICH IS
SENATOR GROVES LEGISLATION- I
WILL PAUSE THAT MR MODERATOR
JUST FOR A MOMENT TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. STERN HERE
STERN HERE JONES JONES HERE
ALLEN EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE GROWTH
PRESENT GROUP HERE- HERTZBERG
HUESO GLARED HERE LARRY HERE LET
ALONE. OKAY QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED- MISTER MODERATELY
PLEASE TURN BACK TO THE LINES SB
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE NAME AND
POSITION WE ARE. YES WE HAVE NO
PRIVILEGES YOU MISTER OKAY VERY
GOOD WE WILL NOW TURN TO ANYONE
WISHING THIS FINE OPPOSITION TO
THIS LEGISLATION- I. DO I HAVE
ANY YEAH I HAVE TO LEAVE SUPPORT
WITNESSES NO. I HAVE NONE AT
THIS POINT- NO ONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SEEING NINE WILL
TURN THE LINES ANYONE WISHING
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE MODERATELY
RIDGE PLEASE. THEIR NUMBERS. IS
PICKING UP ADDITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NOWHERE
ELSE DOING UP AT THIS OKAY
PARDON ME WE DO HAVE ONE NINE
FUELING UP OKAY ONE MOMENT WHILE
THE PROVIDER LINE NUMBER. WILL
OPEN UP LINE FORTY GO AHEAD.
YEAH YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN GO
YES GOOD MORNING. YUP THE
SIMPSONS VOTE NO WEAPONS
PROTECTORS. WE DON'T NEED OIL
PRODUCERS IN CALIFORNIA. OKAY NO
BREAK WITH SMALLER THANK YOU
OKAY WILL REGISTER THAT IS
OPPOSITION THAN ANY OTHERS THAT-
WHICH TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. WE HAVE DOLLARS IN
Q. AT THIS JUNCTURE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS WILL
BRING BACK TO DIS COMMENTS
QUESTIONS- I WOULD JUST SAY YOU
KNOW THE- I. SINCERELY
APPRECIATE. THEM MISTER K. WAS
TESTIMONY N. N. CREATIVITY IN
ATTEMPTING TO. TRY TO FASHION
SOME SOLUTION AND I ALSO WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S-
REPEATED EFFORTS TO RAISE THIS
THE DISPARITY ISSUE BETWEEN
LARGE AND SMALL PRODUCERS- IN
HER DISTRICT AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE KNOW THIS IS AN ONGOING
ISSUE AND- AND FRANKLY THE FACT
THAT- AS A WHOLE THE INDUSTRY IS
EXEMPT FROM LIABILITY PRIOR TO
NINETEEN NINETY SIX OWNERSHIP-
CREATES THIS UNDERLYING DYNAMIC
WHERE ANYONE WHO'S AND- INCURRED
OWNERSHIP. EITHER PASSED THAT-
IS SMALL FOLKS HAVE HELD IT FROM
BEFORE THEN PUT A LOT OF- POLITE
PUTS A LOT OF FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY ON ONLY THE
CURRENT OWNERS AND NOT PREVIOUS
OPERATORS WHICH IS THE
UNDERLYING STRUCTURAL PROBLEM
THAT THE HITCH I'M HAVING WITH
THIS BILL. IS THAT WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME WORKING ON THAT AIM
A. B. TEN FIFTY SAID. FROM IN
THE LEGISLATURE WE PASSED IN
RECOGNIZING THIS MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH FOR THE AUTHOR BUT- WE
ALLOW FOR THE INSTRUMENTS LIKE
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS TO BE USED
TOWARDS THE BONDING
REQUIREMENTS. BUT NOT IN THE
STRUCTURE THIS BILL AND THE
CONCERN IS THAT IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE GOING WELL BY WELL AND
YOUR YOUR SORT OF BITE AND
SEGMENTING YOUR FIELD IN YOUR
OPERATIONS. IF SOMETHING DOES
HAPPEN ON A EITHER MULTI WILL
BASIS OR FOR THE ENTIRE FIELD
THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THE MEANS TO HANDLE- THAT COST
IT WILL END UP GOING BACK TO THE
TAXPAYERS- IT WHEN WITH. WHEN
THE TEN FIFTY SEVEN KICKS IN AND
WE ARE GONNA START GETTING MORE
DATA BACKED. BE CURIOUS FROM THE
OFF. TO ACTUALLY THE SPONSORS OF
THE TESTIMONY IS WHETHER. WE
HAVE ANY DAY DATE BACK YET FROM
THE OPERATOR SIDE WHETHER THOSE
LIABILITIES OR SORT OF
OUTWEIGHING THE BONDING CAPACITY
RIGHT NOW OR THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY. AND IN THE ABSENCE OF THAT
IT'S VERY HARD TO MAKE A
DECISION ON THESE KIND OF REFORM
SO THAT'S WHY I'M I'M NOT
INCLINED TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE
AT THIS MOMENT BUT I REALLY
WOULD INVITE THAT KIND OF INPUT
BECAUSE- CAPITALIZATION COMPARED
TO LIABILITY IS AN IMPORTANT.
DYNAMIC TO GET RIGHT. I GET IN A
CERTAIN CASE LIKE MR K. WOULD WE
CAN SORT OF AT MY GRANDMA'S THAT
BUT AT. WE HAD TO DO SOMETHING
FOR THE WHOLE THE WHOLE SPACE
AND WITHOUT THAT INFORMATION
IT'S- IT'S HARD TO MOVE FOR BUT
I. I WOULD INVITE YOUR YOUR
FEEDBACK THEIR- TEST. FOR ON
THAT. BUT I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
MEASURE- TODAY- IN THIS FORM BUT
OTHERS ARE WELCOME TO MAKE
MOTIONS OR WHATEVER THEY THEY
MAY WISH- IF YOU WANT IF YOU
WANT TO ADEQUATE RESPONSE YET
PLEASE YES IT'S THE CHAIR AND I
HAVE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE DISPARITY. OF THE WAY
TEN FIFTY SEVEN IST FACTS- THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS VERSES THE
LARGE- THE LARGE BUSINESS OWNERS
IT IS A DISPARITY ISSUE IT'S A
BLANKET BILL. AT THAT REQUIRE
SOMEBODY LIKE AN MISTER KAY WHO
HAS PROBABLY THIRTEEN WELL AS
IT'S BEEN IN HIS FAMILY FOR FIVE
THREE. RUNS AND IT'S THERE IT'S
WHAT THEY PAID TO PUT THEIR KIDS%
THROUGH COLLEGE IT'S THEIR JOB
TO HIM AND THE KIDS AND HIS
FATHER AND HIS GRANDFATHER
BEFORE HIM WOULD GO OUT AND WORK
THE WELLS AFTER SCHOOL BEFORE
SCHOOL. OF FOR THE KIDS AND THAT
WAS THEIR JOB RIGHT THAT'S HOW
THEY MADE THEIR INCOME THAT'S
HOW THEY PAID FOR THEIR SMALL
HOUSE IN TAFT THAT'S HOW IT
SHOULD INCOME JUST LIKE US.
THERE'S NO WAY THAT THE SMALL
INDEPENDENT OIL COMPANIES CAN
BOND FOR THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR HEAVEN'S SAKE THEY'RE NOT
WORTH THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
THESE BONDS ARE EVEN AVAILABLE
TO THEM. SO THIS BILL SIMPLY
ADDS AN AVENUE FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO SAVE MONEY AND AS MR K.
WOULD SAID IN TWO MONTHS HE HAS
SAVED ENOUGH MONEY IF CAL JIM
WOOD AUDIT HIS SAVINGS ACCOUNT
THAT HE'S ESTABLISHED THE HE CAN
ABANDON. THAT IS NOT OPERATION.
THIS IS A FAMILY AND MANY OTHER
FAMILIES LIKE HIM THAT ARE
REPRESENTED IN THIS STATE. A TO
HAVE THESE FAMILIES AND JUST GO
OUT OF BUSINESS BECAUSE THERE'S
NO SURE ISSUED BONDS AVAILABLE
TO THEM. BECAUSE THE NUMBER WHEN
THEY CAN'T AFFORD THEM OR NUMBER
TWO THEY'RE JUST NOT IN THE
MARKET YOU CAN'T PURCHASE THEM.
AND IF THE EVIDENCE WILL SHOW IF
YOU GUYS LOOK AT IT THAT. YOU
CAN BARELY GET A BOND FOR
MILLION DOLLARS POSSIBLY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. BUT YOU HAVE
TO. IT'S YOU HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE ABOUT THE EQUITY RIGHT
ABOUT THE BALANCE. AND SOME
MAJOR CORPORATIONS CAN SIGN A
LETTER OF CREDIT. AND NEVER EVEN
HAVE TO HAVE A BLIP ON THEIR
FINANCIAL RAIDERS SCREEN OUT
ALL. FAMILIES A HUNDRED OR SO
FAMILIES THAT OPERATE LIKE THE
K. WOODS DO. THEY HAVE TO HAWK
THEIR HOME THEIR- EVERYTHING
DOWN TO THE PAPER TOWELS IN THE
CUPBOARD TO EVEN ACQUIRE A BOND.
NOT AVAILABLE THE STATE ACCOUNT.
AS MR MONTAIGNE SAID BECAUSE OF
THE INSURANCE PURPOSES IN THE
POLICIES WE PASSED. MISTER CHAIR
YOU AND I HAVE HAD LENGTHLY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE AN ORPHAN IN ABOUT
. UNDERNEATH THE MALLS NEWPORT
BEACH IN MALIBU ACROSS THE
STATE. THIS IS A SOLUTION AND
THE OIL PERSON I REPRESENT 70%
OF THE STATE'S OIL THIS IS A
TRUE SOLUTION. TO THE PROBLEM
THE CALLER ANNA WHO CALLED IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL SAYS
THAT THERE SHOULD BE NO OIL IN
CALIFORNIA. WELL I DID A
PRESENTATION LAST WEEK THAT THAT
YOU'RE ALLOWED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR FURTHER
CONVERSATION. CALIFORNIANS USE
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION BARRELS
OF OIL EVERY DAY AND IT'S GOT TO
COME FROM SOME PLACE BECAUSE WE
HAVE NOT REDUCED OUR PROJECTS
ARE USE. OR CONSUME. SO WE'RE
GETTING IT RIGHT NOW BY
BULLDOZING DOWN THE AMAZON
RAINFOREST WE ARE GETTING IT
FROM COUNTRIES THAT ARE HOSTILE
TO THE LGBT COMMUNITY THEY HANG
THEM THEY BEAT THEM. WE GET NEW
OIL FROM SAUDI ARABIA WHERE THEY
DON'T LET WOMEN VOTE OR WOMEN
DRIVE. AND WE FIND THAT BECAUSE-
CONSUMPTION HAS NOT CHANGED SO
THE IDEA IS TO BRING FORTH GOOD
SOLUTIONS LIKE THIS ONE AND I
KNOW YOU DON'T AGREE BUT IT
REALLY IS. IF YOU WANT TO WORK
ON A CONVERSATION LET IT OUT OF
THE- COMMITTEE WILL WORK ON IT.
I GIVE YOU MY WORD WE'VE BEEN
WORKING TOGETHER ON THINGS FOR A
LONG TIME. SO IF THIS COULD GO
FORWARD M. I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR'S COMMENTS ABOUT NOT
SUPPORTING IT- WE COULD WORK OUT
A SOLUTION THAT ACTUALLY HELPS
BENEFIT THE SMALL PRODUCERS.
DOESN'T FORCE THEM OUT OF
BUSINESS AND WILL ALSO BRING
SOME TYPE OF EQUITY WITH TEN
FIFTY SEVEN WHICH- AGAIN NEEDED
TO BE ADDRESSED BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE ORPHANED AND ABANDONED
WELLS THAT NEED TO BE TAKEN CARE
OF I'M ON YOUR SIDE ON THAT. I
GET THAT BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
VIABLE SOLUTION AND PUTTING
SMALL INDEPENDENT OPERATORS OUT
OF BUSINESS. BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE FINANCIAL CAPITAL TO BE
ABLE TO BOND OR PURCHASE A BOND
IS NOT A GOOD SOLUTION. THANK
YOU FOR THAT CENTER. YES THIS
RESTAURANT JUST TO. AB QUICK
CLARIFICATION- YOU MENTIONED IN
YOUR COMMENTS THAT YOU WEREN'T
INCLINED TO SUPPORT IT WHICH I
UNDERSTAND AND- SO. MAYBE WITH
THE AUTHORED YOU KNOW
RECOGNIZING THAT YOU ALL HAVE
HAD VERY SUBSTANTIAL OF-
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING MULTIPLE
THINGS. AND I DON'T MEAN TO PUT
ON THE SPOT BUT IS THERE WILL
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU SAID I'VE GOT
AN IDEA YOU'RE NOT INCLINED TO
SUPPORT IT WHAT WHAT- WHAT WOULD
MAKE ME CENTER I COULD THERE'S A
DOOR OVER THERE WITH THE DOOR
OPEN IS THE NINETEEN NINETY SIX-
LIABILITY WAIVER SO IF. IF THE
IF LARGE COMPANIES WERE SUBJECT
TO UNDERLYING OPERATIONALIZE
ABILITY PARTY NINETY SIX SO THAT
THEY CAN BACKSTOPS THOSE KIND
OPERATIONS THEN I THINK IT WOULD
BE FAIR TO ENDEAVOR INTO THIS
SORT OF FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
CURRENT OPERATORS BUT IF THERE'S
NO BACKSTOP. AND IT'S ALL ON
TAXPAYERS BEHIND THAT. THAT'S A
THAT'S WHY CURRENT SO THAT'S SO
I JUST WANT TO CORRECT THAT YEAR
IN THE RESPONSE AND THOUGHT NO
DISRESPECT TO YOU ALL WITH IT'S
NOT ON TAXPAYERS AND THE
ORPHANED AND ABANDONED WELL FUN
OTHER THAN WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
RECENTLY PUT INTO IT FROM THE
BUDGET IN THE ACCESS THAT WE
HAVE IS TAXPAYERS BUT OIL
COMPANIES ARE TAXPAYERS TOO.
WHETHER THEY PAY OILED- TAXES
WITH THE PAY FEES PENALTIES
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYEES WAGES TAXES
SO PART OF THAT MANY USERS BUT
THE MAJORITY OF THE- A MAJORITY
OF ALL A CAL JIM OPERATIONS ARE
FUNDED BY. THE END OF IT THE
PRODUCERS- THE ORGANIZATION
THEMSELVES THE INDUSTRY THEY
1100% FUND CAL JAMMING CAL JIM'S
OPERATIONS AND THEN CAL JIM'S
OPERATIONS INCLUDE OR IN AN
ABANDONED WELL FUNDS- WHICH IS A
SOLUTION THAT I BROUGHT TO YOU
BEFORE THAT WOULD BENEFIT LABOR
BENEFIT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS THE PRODUCERS. YOU
CLICK ACCESS THINK THAT YOU A
THIS IS PROBABLY A BAD MAY SINCE
I'M TO BEG YOUR VOTE BUT IF
YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO BE HERE FOR
ANOTHER YEAR BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO BE A SUPERVISOR I'D
REALLY LIKE TO WORK WITH
SOMEBODY OF ESTABLISH A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THAT REALLY
KNOWS THAT I'M HERE TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. BY APPRECIATE YOUR
ROUTING- I TOOK THAT AS A
COMPLIMENT I DO I TAKE SOME KIND
OF COMPLEMENT THE LIKE DISLIKE
OKAY. I REMEMBER LET. SEND ME A
LIKE IT OR THE ORDER THEM TO ME
- BIG EYES BEGGING- SO MISTER
CHAIR FIVE CAN- I MAKE THE
MOTION FOR THE BILL AND YOU KNOW
IF YOU CAN YOU KNOW IF YOU FEEL
LIKE THERE'S CONCERT
CONVERSATION M. AND THE BILL
FORWARD SO THAT YOU AN AUTHOR
CAN KEEP YOU KNOW HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS I THINK
THAT MIGHT BE A PRODUCTIVE WAY
TO MOVE FORWARD- YOU KNOW ONE
OTHER THING I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT ON THAT. THE PERSON THAT
SPOKE IN OPPOSITION I THINK THAT
WAS VERY INSTRUCTIVE FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS TO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE THERE THERE IS A THERE'S A-
AS AN INTEREST GROUP IN
CALIFORNIA I DON'T AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT LADY WAS FROM OR- IF
SHE'S EVEN WITH THE GROUP BUT
THERE'S A- THERE THERE'S A GROUP
OF. CITIZENS IN IN CALIFORNIA
THAT BELIEVE THAT WITHOUT. LADY
SAID THAT WE SHOULDN'T HAVE WHAT
IN CALIFORNIA. WELL I KNOW THAT
THE GOVERNOR AND MANY PEOPLE
WANT TO MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION.
YOU KNOW WE KEEP MOVING UP THE
TIME FRAME FROM TWENTY FORTY TO
THIRTY FIVE TO THIRTY TO TWENTY
SEVEN TOTAL YOU KNOW WHATEVER
IT'S GONNA BE. BUT WE'RE NOT
THERE YET AND I THINK WE HAVE TO
BE. REASONABLE PEOPLE HERE ON
THE DÍAS TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WORLD. A LONG WAYS IF THE
ULTIMATE GOAL BY SOME PEOPLE IN
THE STATE IS TO GET TO ZERO OIL
. WE GOT A LONG WAYS TO GO IF
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE GOAL AND I'M
CERTAINLY THAT'S NOT MY GOAL BUT
IF THAT IS THE GOAL AND THAT'S
WHERE THE- ALL ASEAN
CALIFORNIA'S GONNA MOVE. WELL
WE'RE A LONG WAYS AWAY FROM THAT
AND SO IN THE MEANTIME WE'VE GOT
TO COME UP WITH A REASONABLE
SOLUTION SUCH AS WHAT CENTER
GROVE IS SUGGESTING AND THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU'RE HAVING
CHORE SO I WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
WE MOVE THE BILL FORWARD THANK
YOU FOR THE MOTION- SO I BELIEVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS- YES. SIR
LEONARD. THANK YOU MISTER MISTER
CHAIR I THINK. THE DIFFICULT
THING HERE IS WE HAVE A BILL
THAT WAS ENACTED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THERE'S A QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER. IT NEEDS A CHANCE
TO WORK I THINK THE AUTHOR IS
SAYING IT DOESN'T WORK. AND IS
DOING THIS. ALREADY AND WHEN. HE
NOTWITHSTANDING THE CONVERSATION
THAT WENT BACK AND FORTH HERE.
YOU WERE TRYING TO. BOUNCE
BETWEEN TWO GOALS. THE GOALS OF
WHAT KEEPS. SMALL INDEPENDENT
PRODUCERS BUT THE GOALS THAT I
EXPERIENCED AND I HESITATE TO
MENTION. JOHN BECAUSE IT MAKES.
SENSE OUR ARMED BUT BUT IN MY
JOB WE HAD TO DO WITH BILLIONS
DOLLARS OF UNFUNDED ORPHAN WELLS
AND WAS GOING TO FALL ON THE
TAXPAYERS AND THAT BILL WAS
ENACTED SO THAT THAT PRACTICE
WOULD STOP. A. N. SO V. IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THIS MAY BE A PLACE
TO GO AT SOME POINT BUT IT'S NOT
TOTALLY RIPE YET. BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO ALLOW THE OTHER THING I
WISH THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL WAS
HERE THERE'S THE SIMULTANEOUS
HEARING SAID SHE'S NOT HERE I
THINK SHE COULD OFFER US A
PERSPECTIVE IF YOU WERE SITTING
HERE AS WELL. AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE CHAIR AND THE
AUTHOR TO KEEP. A CONVERSATION
GOING BUT I JUST DON'T THINK
THIS IS ROCKED AND- BOB AND- YOU
KNOW YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO
APPRECIATE SOMEBODY THAT ARE-
MORE THAN ADEQUATELY REPRESENTS
THEIR CONSTITUENTS AND I JUST
KNOW. THAT THE AUTHOR DOES BUT-
AND I JUST CHECKED THAT'S WHERE
WE ARE PRESHEAF THE COMMENTS
SENATOR- SO. ARE YOU I GUESS
I'LL CLARIFY. SAN WOULD YOU LIKE
THEM FOR. FROM THE VICE CHAIR TO
BE ON THE BILL AS IS WITH NO
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR OR
WOULD YOU PREFER- THE MOTION BE
ON AMENDMENT TO ADD IN THE
STRIKING OF THE- NINETY SIX
EXEMPTION LIABILITY AND ADDING
THAT TO THE BILL AND THEN. I
WOULD BE OPEN TO SUPPORTING. SO
THEN I CAN'T SAY YES TO THAT SIR
IN THE REASON WHY IS BECAUSE AND
EVEN THOUGH I REPRESENT 70% OF
THE STATE'S OIL I REALLY DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PRIOR TO NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
AND I'M JUST BEING HONEST AND
NINE NINETY SIX SO- IF WE COULD
HAVE A DISCUSSION ON YET. MAYBE
I DON'T KNOW PETITIONS TO
RECONSIDER I DON'T KNOW I DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION. RIGHT
pAND IF. IF I IF I KNEW THE GOODS
AND BADS BECAUSE JUST LIKE THAT
MY COLLEAGUE. WHO IS THE FORMER
SECRETARY OF. RESOURCES HE HE
GROANS MODE YES SO HE- HE BRINGS
THAT IT CONSISTENTLY AND- I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE AND IN BECAUSE THAT'S MAKE
THE BILL RIGHT. RIGHT IT'S NOT
RIGHT YET BUT LET'S MAKE IT
RIGHT. THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
YOU GUYS ARE HANGING YOUR HAT
AGAIN ON A BILL THAT PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN THAT
WE DON'T HAVE DATA BACK FROM.
BUT ON THE GROUND SMALL
INDEPENDENT PRODUCERS. CANNOT
GET AN ASSUREDLY BOND YOU KEEP
IT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE IT WOULD BE
LIKE ASKING YOU SIR AND I KNOW
YOU HAVE. YOUR PERSON OF MEANS
YOU PROVIDE FOR YOUR FAMILY BUT
I WANT YOU TO COME UP WITH
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS. AND
MAYBE YOUR DAD COULDN'T I CAN'T.
I CAN'T COME UP WITH THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS. IN THE SMALL
PRODUCERS CAN'T AND THERE'S NOT
AN INSURANCE LIABILITY I CREATED
TO WORKERS COMP IN THE REAL
WORLD I'M A BUSINESS OWNER.
AFTER THAT IN BECAUSE HE HATES
THAT IMMIGRANTS. AND AS A
BUSINESS OWNER IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE WORKERS COMP WE HAD TO
COME UP WITH A TWO MILLION
DOLLAR BOND. WHAT IS NOT WORTH
TO KNOW. SO IT'S JUST THE I. CAN
SET THE WORK FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN THE- PRODUCE. AND
EQUITY LIKE I SAID MAJOR
COMPANIES BLIP ON THERE DOESN'T
EVEN. AFFECT THEM UNDERSTOOD
MILLION IS NOTHING TO TAKE THEIR
CLOTHES. SURE IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TELL ME JUST FOR THE RECORD
YES- I DON'T. EIGHT HOUR AGO
YOUR- A GENTLEMAN WORDS SHOW IN
THE TWO YEARS. SENATOR LAYERED-
EARLIER RECORD SHE SHE- CALLED
ME REGULAR THE RULES. FOR
ROLLING MY EYES I START TO WEAR
MY MASK OVER MY EYES. THIS
MISTER CHAIR IF THAT THE
SETTLERS RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
FOR THE CON MOST RECENT YEAR YES
ON THE MOTION IS A GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS FROM HERE OR WHAT
IS A GO FOR YES IT WOULD BE. TO
RE REFER TO COME TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS AND
BASED ON THE CONVERSATION HERE
IF IT IF IT- IT DOES NOT. HAVE
PASSED TODAY WOULD I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION BUT AT THIS POINT AND
WE DOESN'T KNOW RECOMMENDATION
OKAY AND YOU WOULD RATHER HAVE
THE CONVERSATION ON
RECONSIDERATION RATHER THAN HAVE
THE CONVERSATION- APPROPRIATIONS
. INHABITED ADDRESS INFORMATION
OKAY SO CHEN STANDS AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- PRESENTATION YOUR ADVOCACY
AND- THE ALWAYS LIVELY COLLOQUY
HERE AND SENATE NATURAL RESOURCE
AND WATER WAS CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
ONE S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS STERN NO STERN
NODE JONES I JONES HI ALAN
EGGMAN. EGGMAN NO GROWTH HI
GROVE HI HERTZBERG HERTZBERG NO
HUESO. HUESO HI LEARN NO LAYERED
NOTE LOAN. AND HAS THREE OKAY
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES WILL
LEAVE IT ON CALL AND- CONTINUE
THAT CONVERSATION MISTER
CHAIRMAN- YES JUST IN CASE AND
WE'VE GOT A LONG YES I AM. AND
YOU WANT TO MAKE IT AND I'M ON
I'M ON JUDICIARY ALSO TODAY
WHICH HAS. I DON'T EVEN KNOW I
WRITE SOME KIND OF MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION ESTO ES AUTHOR
OR I OR MR WAYS OR NOT HERE AT
THE END OF THE DAY. WHENEVER IT
COMES UP YOU MAKE MEMORABLE FIND
OF A MOTION FOR MAKING
EVERYTHING YEAH YOU GOT THAT
MISTER CHAIR YES ALSO IN THE
INTEREST OF GOD KNOWS WHEN
PEOPLE BE HERE. TRUMP TO GET I
WOULD MOVE THEM. ONE WE WILL
MOVE THE- WE WILL MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR NOW. THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR- SO THAT THAT'S A MOTION
FROM SENATOR HERTZBERG. AND IT
WE HAVE A SB THIRTEEN NINETY TWO
S. B. EIGHT NINETY FOUR AND IS.
SB FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN- OKAY
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT HOLES IN
AMERICA'S CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM FOR
S. B. THIRTEEN NINETEEN THIRTEEN
NINETY TWO FILE ITEM FIVE S. B.
EIGHT NINE FOUR FILE ITEM TEN SB
FOURTEEN. NINETY SEVEN STERN ALL
RIGHTS STERN ALRIGHT JONES JONES
ALL RIGHT ALLEN IT. EGGMAN GROVE
. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG DRIVEWAY
SO. HUESO ARI LAYERED LAYERED
ARE ALONE. OKAY I'LL BE RIGHT WE
ARE IN FILE ORDER BUT- I'LL
DEFER TO THE AUTHORS HERE THE
CHAIRS UP SECOND BUT- YOU CAN
COME ON UP CENTER COVER YOUR IF
YOU WANT TO. ZEND OTHER YOUR ON
THE TWO RIGHT NOW NO YOU'RE NOT
ANYMORE WE MISS YOU. THAT'S HOW
MUCH YOU MISS. YEAH COMMITTEE.
JUSTIN THIS CAN ALL THEY FORGET
TO HEAR THIS NOW ACTUALLY I DO I
APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE JUDICIARY
DOES HAVE ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
BILLS YES SIR WORK COME ON UP SB. ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN WATER
INNOVATION. HE'S INSURANCE
PLEASE- PLEASE FEEL THE FEEL THE
PRINT FEEL FREE TO PRESS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN THE WATER
INNOVATION ACT AND DROUGHT
RESILIENCY. ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. CLIMATE CHANGE IS HAVING A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S
WATER SYSTEMS ALONG WITH AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ONE GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINATION SUBSIDENCE AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA. NU IN
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES AND
MANAGEMENT APPROACHES ARE NEEDED
TO MEET AND OVERCOME THESE
CHALLENGES WHILE OUR STATE IS A
BEACON OF INTERVIEW. IN OTHER
UTILITY BASED MARKETS LIKE
ENERGY CALIFORNIA'S WATER SECTOR
FALLS BEHIND OTHER AREAS AND
EVEN OTHER COUNTRIES IN THE
DEVELOPMENT AND ADOPTION OF
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES. SB
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN WOULD
ESTABLISH THE INITIATIVE TO
ADVANCE WATER INNOVATION AND
DROUGHT RESILIENCY AT THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH AND
THEM IMPORTANT THING ABOUT THIS
IS DROUGHT RESILIENCY WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH- CALIFORNIA AS A STATE
THAT IS DROUGHT RESISTANT. THE
INITIATIVE WOULD COORDINATE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER TO HELP
ACHIEVE ITS GOALS WHICH INCLUDE
REVIEWING REGULATIONS THAT THAT
MAY LIMIT OR INHIBIT INNOVATION
- AS WELL AS MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
STREAMLINING. OR REVISING THOSE
REGULATIONS OPR IS TASKED WITH
THIS RESPONSIBILITY AS IT IS THE
IN THE BEST POSITION TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS FROM A VARIETY
OF PERSPECTIVES. AND DURING
DETERMINE WHAT MAY BE THE BEST
WAYS TO ADVANCE INNOVATION IN
THE WATER SECTOR. FROM BETTER
DATA MANAGEMENT TO SEEK REFORM
THERE ARE A MULTITUDE OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR REMOVING
OBSTACLES IN THIS AREA. BUT IT
WILL TAKE A THOROUGH REVIEW BY
OPR TO ISOLATE THE BEST EXAMPLES
FOR MAKING POSITIVE CHANGE.
ADDITIONALLY THE INITIATIVE WILL
. STEP NEW EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES
REVIEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR PILOT
PROGRAMS ISSUE GRANTS TO WATER
AGENCIES FOR EVALUATING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES IN THEIR WATER
SYSTEMS. AND REVIEW INVESTMENT
TRENDS FOR INNOVATION WATER
UTILITIES RATEPAYERS AND
ECOSYSTEMS WILL BENEFIT FROM THE
BROADER ADOPTION OF WATER
INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY. THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS CORRECTLY
STATES THAT THERE ARE SOME.
CURRENT WORKING A DRESS
INNOVATION. BUT THIS BUT THE
STATE SHOULD NOT SHY AWAY FROM
ITS IMPORTANT ROLE AS A
FACILITATOR AND SUPPORTER A
PROPOSED SOLUTIONS FROM BOTH FOR
FROM BOTH THESE EFFORTS AND ALSO
FROM THE WORK OUTLINED IN THE
BILL. THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE
AS RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THESE
INSTITUTIONS MAY NEED
LEGISLATIVE OR REGULATORY ACTION
IN IMPLEMENT. ESTABLISHING A
DEDICATED ENTITY TO FURTHER
FURTHER WATER INNOVATION EFFORTS
WOULD HELP THE STATE ACHIEVE ITS
GOAL OF A HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
BY EXPLORING NEW APPROACHES TO
SECURE SAFE DRINKING WATER.
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AS YOU KNOW THIS ISSUE IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND IT IS NO
EXAGGERATION TO SAY THAT THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA. DEPENDS ON
OUR ABILITY TO USE EVERY DROP OF
WATER TO ITS FULLEST CAPACITY
AND THE FUTURE OF OUR COUNTRY.
OF OUR COUNTRY'S FOOD SUPPLY
DEPEND OUT FOOD SUPPLY AND
SAFETY AND SECURITY AND SECURITY
DEPENDS UPON OUR DROUGHT
PROOFING OUR STATE. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN NINETY
SEVEN R. DANIELLE BLANCHARD
HAYDN- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
ADRIAN COLBERT WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNT. MARC IMPROVE. WELL HERE
FROM PERSONALLY SUPPORT WITNESS
COME ON. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DANIEL
BLASTED HIDE ITH CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIESASSOCIATION
WE REPRESENT PUBLIC AGENCIES
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES AND
PUBLICLY OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE ARE PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR SB
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN AS SENATOR
COVER YOUR OWN NOTED THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO GRAPPLE
WITH THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE THE
STATE'S WHAT. IS WELL FIRST
DECEMBER. PATTERNS AND LEVEL.
THE STATE'S WATER SYSTEMS ALSO
FACE MYRIAD OTHER CHALLENGES
INCLUDING AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINATION
SUBSIDENCE AND NUMEROUS
ECOLOGICAL CHALLENGES.
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES ARE NEEDED
TO ENSURE THE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY OF OUR WATER
SUPPLY. SENIOR IS MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
PURSUING INNOVATION IN ADOPTING
NEW TECHNOLOGIES BUT MORE WORK
IS NEEDED. THE INITIATIVE TO
ADVANCE WATER INNOVATION AND
DROUGHT RESILIENCY OPR WOULD
POSITION THE STATE AS A PARTNER
AND FACILITATOR FOR INNOVATION
IN OUR STATE COMPLEMENTING AND
AMPLIFYING. EXISTING ACADEMIC
AND OTHER EFFORTS IT WOULD HELP
ADVANCE IS STAYING ABILITY AND
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S GOAL OF
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND WOULD ALSO
ADMIT RECONCILIATIONS AND DATES
WITH RESIGN FOR. HEALTH FOR WITH
STAFFERS TO FIND A SUPPORT
INNOVATION THE WATERS. IN SENIOR
ASK FOR FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
FOR THIS PURPOSE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY WE ARE DRIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TESLA IS
MESSY- PLEASE COME FORWARD MR
COVERT. WELL GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND SENATOR
CAFIERO MY NAME'S ADRIAN COVERT
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC
POLICY AT THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
ON BEHALF OF THE LARGEST
EMPLOYERS OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA THE BAY AREA COUNCIL IS
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR S. B. ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS YOUR AYE VOTE
CALIFORNIA'S THREE TRILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMY IS BASED ON OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE SAFE RELIABLE
WATER TO OUR HOMES BUSINESSES
FARMS AND ECOSYSTEMS AS OF THIS
MORNING 96% OF CALIFORNIA'S LAND
MASSES RETURNED TO A STATE. OF
SEVERE DROUGHT NEARLY HALF THAT
LET AN EXTREME DROUGHT LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LABS RECENTLY
ESTIMATED THAT WARMING
TEMPERATURES WILL EFFECTIVELY
ELIMINATE THE SIERRA SNOWPACK
SOURCE OF ROUGHLY 40% OF OUR
FRESHWATER MOST YEARS BEGINNING
IN THE TWENTY FORTIES CALIFORNIA
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
ADAPT TO THIS NEW NORMAL WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT INNOVATIONS IN THE
WATER SECTOR HOWEVER WATER
TECHNOLOGY ACCOUNTED FOR LESS
THAN 1% OF ALL VENTURE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS IN TWENTY TWENTY BY
ESTABLISHING THE INITIATIVE TO
ADVANCE WATER INNOVATION DROUGHT
RESILIENCY AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH SB
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN WOULD ALLOW
CALIFORNIA. TO PARTNER WITH
RESEARCHERS ENTREPRENEURS LOCAL
WATER AGENCIES AND OTHERS TO
FACILITATE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
DEPLOYMENT OF THE WORLD'S NEXT
GENERATION OF INNOVATIVE WATER
TECHNOLOGIES A GROWING WORLD
CLASS WATER INNOVATION SECTOR
WOULD HELP CALIFORNIA MEET ITS
NATURAL RESOURCES GOALS. WHILE
CREATING NEW BUSINESSES AND NEW
JOBS AND HELP SHORTEN MY
TESTIMONY TODAY ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS. CALIFORNIA WATER
SERVICE COMPANY IMAGINE H. TWO
O. NORTH BAY LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
AND WATER RE USE THANK YOU FOR
TAKING MY COMMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIVAL THANK
YOU SO MUCH- NOW WILL TURN TO
GENERAL SUPPORTERS IN A GENERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF ANY OF
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WAS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE SEEING NONE. MODERATE
APPOINTMENT ALIGNS- FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- JUST FOR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. YOU CAN SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE FIRST GO TO
LINE THIRTY EIGHT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
THAT A LOT SO ON BEHALF OF WATER
REUSE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. ONE
FIFTY FIVE. MARTIN READ OUT THIS
ON BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SIR NEXT. ONE FIFTY NINE. HI
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SHARING INVOLVED IS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. NINE SIXTY EIGHT. RIGHT
NOT ROMAN I'M HAPPY SENATE WATER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT. LINE
SEVENTY ONE. I'M SORRY BUT
DELIVERY OF FORTY NINE SB ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN. OKAY AND I AM
READY FOR SB ONE FORTY THREE
THAT'S OKAY WHAT WILL GO TO THE
NEXT WITNESS. LINE TWENTY NINE.
I WANT TO SHARE MEMBERS RICHARD
BILL GETS ON THE HALF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT. LINE TWENTY ONE
. GOOD MORNING CATHY SCHAEFER ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY ON THE REALITY PROJECT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
. NINE FIFTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBER MELISSA HI YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT. OVER THE LINE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OKAY
VERY GOOD- WILL TURN AND
OPPOSITION I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANY REGISTERED ON FILE- BUT
IF ANYONE SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION THE MEASURE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE
MODERATOR WOULD TURN THE LINES
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN FOR DOING
UP AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU I
WILL TURN. SORRY WE'LL TURN IT
BACK TO THE MEMBERS SAID EARLIER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
STRUCTURE. I KNOW THAT LAST YEAR
SENATOR CAFIERO ATTEMPTED- A
SIMILAR EFFORT AND HAS CHANGED
THE- ORGANIZATION THAT WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD THING IT MEETS THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE EXPRESSED OF LAST
YEAR. AND ALSO I WOULD REITERATE
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED I KNOW IN THE MAJOR
DROUGHT EARLY PART OF THE LAST
DECADE IS THAT EVERYBODY CAME
OUT OF THE WOODWORK WITH SOME
KIND OF THING THAT WAS
TECHNOLOGICAL EFFICIENCY IN THE
STATE HAD NO WAY TO VET IT FOR.
IT IN AN ORGANIZED WAY TO DEAL
WITH IT AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT IS IT PROVIDES
IT NOT THINK PRICKLY NOW THAT
WE'RE BACK IN THE MIDDLE OF
SEVERE DROUGHT THIS IS A REALLY
VITAL THING TO HAPPEN SO THAT WE
DON'T MISS. THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
BE THE SHIPS OF THE PROPER TIME
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL VERY GOOD
I WILL RECOGNIZE THAT IS A
MOTION IN THE OTHERS WITHIN A
COMMON. ON THE BILL- APPRECIATE
THE MEASURE I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT
IT BACK AND- LOOKS LIKE OPR MAY
BE MAY JUST BE THE RIGHT HOME
FOR THIS AFTER ALL SO- WHICH YOU
WANNA BE SPORTING MEASURE AND-
WITH. THE LATEST. HOLIDAY THE
STATEMENT BY EXTENDED LAYERED
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SO THE
MOTION IS. TO PASS BUT FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHIEF CAN SOMEONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE FILE
ITEM THREE S. B. ELEVEN NINETY
SEVEN THE MOTIONS TO PASS THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN. STERN ALRIGHT JONES JONES
ALL RIGHT ALLEN. EGGMAN GROVE
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG RIGHT HUESO-
HUESO AYE LAYERED AYE LAYERED
AYE LIMÓN. REGULAR MEASURES FIVE
VOTES WILL EVEN CALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH APPRECIATE YOU JUMPING
ME UP IN THE LINE NO WORRIES
I'LL JUMP BACK IN LINE NOW WITH
FILE ITEM TO- AND- IF I CAN HAND
THE CAPITAL CAN YOU STICK AROUND
FOR THIS ONE YEAH ACTION GET
READY. WE CAN YOU STICKER ON
THEM YOU'RE GOING TO I CAN YOU
CAN YOU. CONTINUE HE- YEAH. I IT
MR VERY CHAIR WILL WILL YOU TO
GIVE A PRESENT FOR HERE FROM ICE
THERE ALRIGHT- OKAY. RIGHT
MISTER CHAIRMAN I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER
TWO. SB ELEVEN I'M SORRY SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE I AM
INDEED AND I'M JUST LOOKING FOR
MY FOLDER ONE SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE MY NOTES. CAN READ YOURS
HELLO ONE SECOND. YEAH.
I AM VERY GOOD WELL MEMBERS I'D
LIKE PRESENT SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE WHICH WOULD- AMENDED
IMPORT PROVISION THE COASTAL ACT
OF NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AROUND
INDUSTRIAL DEVELOPMENT
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THE OIL
AND GAS FACILITIES WHAT WE VIEW
IS A LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW
THAT ALLOWS FOR OIL AND GAS
FACILITIES IN THE COASTAL ZONE-
TO BE A QUOTE COASTAL DEPENDENT
INDUSTRIAL USE WHICH ALLOWS THEM
TO BE PERMITTED EVEN IF OTHER
PROVISIONS CLOSE LIKE AREN'T
SATISFIED- SO THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT. OF THAT KIND OF
EXPANDED WILLING GAS DEVELOPMENT
FROM BEING CONSIDERED ACOSTA
DEPENDENT JUST REALLY USE AND
THEREFORE THERE BY EXEMPTING
ITSELF FROM CERTAIN OTHER
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS UNDER
THE COASTAL ACT AND SUBJECT THAT
SAME DEVELOPMENT TO THE VERY
SAME PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT EVERY OTHER- COASTAL
DEPENDENT USES YOUR BUILDING A
HOTEL HOUSING- IT MAKES NO SENSE
FOR THE THRESHOLDS ON THAT KIND
DEVELOPMENT TO BE HIGHER THAN IT
WOULD BE- FOR THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY FOR IT SO FOR THAT
REASON WE WANT TO CORRECT THIS-
THIS THIS WHOLE IN CALIFORNIA
LAW AND IN THE PROCESS- BRING A
EVEN. KEEL TO HOW WE DO
PERMITTING AROUND THESE KINDS OF
FACILITIES- IN THE ZONE- THAT WE
KNOW SO SENSITIVE AND WE'VE SEEN
THE IMPACT- OVER AND OVER AGAIN
IT'S NOT JUST THE HIGH PROFILE
STUFF THAT THAT ENDS UP ON OUR
SHORES IN ORANGE YOUR SAN DIEGO
FROM THE OFFSHORE SPILLS BUT
IT'S THE IT'S THE STUFF CLOSER
TO HOME- IT'S STORAGE SITES- AND
PRODUCTION FACILITIES THAT. THAT
STILL IMPEDE HABITAT. YOU HEALTH
OF OUR- OCEANS AND FRANKLY UP
THE- CAN THAT. THEY HAVE TO LIVE
BY THESE INDUSTRY USES SO I'M
VERY PROUD TO OFFER THIS MEASURE
AND WE HAVE A- A GREAT TEAM OF
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD HANDED
OVER TO MY LEAD SUPPORT WINS.
THANK YOU SIR STERNAL HAVE
WITNESSES IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
HEARING FIRST. PLEASE PROCEED
AND IF YOU CAN GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE MANAGER WITH
CALIFORNIA A CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS FORMERLY C.
LCV. ACCORDING TO A RECENT
REPORT BY THE L. A. L. TITLED
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. BESIDES AFFECTING
NATURAL RESOURCES. THE HAZARDS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE HAVE MAJOR
IMPACTS ON PUBLIC HEALTH. SAFETY
AS WELL AS PROPERTY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AS SUCH
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS ALL
AFFECTS ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
EMPLOYERS AND WORKERS. ALONG
WITH THE STATE'S ECONOMY BUDGET
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS
TRANSPORTATION AND WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS HOUSING MARKET AND
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES. THE POLICY
OUTLINED IN SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE. IS ONE OF THE MANY STEPS
THE STATE CAN TAKE IN ORDER TO
UPDATE. AND CHANGE OUTDATED CAL
. IF OIL AND GAS DEVELOPMENT
THIS IN IN THIS THE STATURE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHICH
FAVORS OIL AND GAS DEVELOPMENT
IN THE COASTAL ZONE. SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE SIMPLY ASK THE OIL
INDUSTRY AND GROWING GAS
INDUSTRY TO MEET THE SAME
STANDARD OF COASTAL COMMISSION
OVERSIGHT AS ALL OTHER COASTAL
DEVELOPMENTS. AND TO COMPLY WITH
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS IN THE STATE
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL ACT THE
VIRTUALLY ALL OTHER PROJECTS
MUST COMPLY WITH. THIS BILL
REMOVES A LOOPHOLE KNOWN AS THE
COASTAL AND DEPENDENT INDUSTRIAL
USE OVERRIDE. THE PERMITTING OF
OIL AND GAS AND COASTAL ZONE
WHICH INCLUDES OFFSHORE OIL
DEVELOPMENT IN NEW OR EXPANDED
REFINERIES AND PETROCHEMICAL
PLANTS. THE OVER I WAS USED TO
APPROVED. A SOMEWHAT RECENT NEW
OIL AND GAS DEVELOPMENT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IN LONG BEACH THIS
PROJECT AND OTHERS WERE APPROVED
BECAUSE THEY CONFORM WITH THE
OVER RIGHT PROPOSED PROVISIONS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO OIL AND
GAS PROJECTS. WELL AT THE SAME
TIME ACTUALLY VIOLATING OTHER
COASTAL ACT POLICIES. IS TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND IT'S ABOUT TIME
THAT THIS OUTDATED LAW BE
UPDATED TO STOP ENABLING
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT RATIONS
THAT DO NOT COMPLY WITH CRITICAL
PROVISIONS OF CALIFORNIA LAW. IN
REVISING OVER A POLICY THIS BILL
RESTRICTS NEW OR EXPANDED OIL
AND GAS DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS
PETROCHEMICAL FACILITIES. WELL
ACTUALLY ENABLING OFFSHORE
RENEWABLE ENERGY DEVELOPMENT.
REMOVING COASTAL ACT POLICY
READING BECAUSE ALL POLICIES
THAT PROMOTE NEW WORKS IN OIL
AND GAS DEVELOPMENT. IS NOT ONLY
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
DECARBONISATION CLIMATE GOALS.
BUT AND ALSO ENCOURAGES A
TRANSITION AWAY FROM
UNSUSTAINABLE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY DETRIMENTAL
PRACTICE. IS INDUSTRY HAVE
EVADED OVERSIGHT IN THE COASTAL
COMMISSION SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AND IF YOU CAN WRAP UP
WE'VE GOT ANOTHER WITNESSES ALSO
WANTS TO MINUTES. NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE SURE THEIR SUBJECT
ASSEMBLY STANDER AS THE REST OF.
INDUSTRIES IN THE STATE. WE URGE
YOU'RE EITHER ON THIS BILL
THANKS THE- FINGER MUCH. I GET
IT. FOR JUST FIVE MINUTES BY
WE'RE MOVING. OKAY SOMEBODY
MOVEMENT WE GOT A MOTION ALL
RIGHT I CAN TEST IT. THANK YOU
THE MOST EFFICIENT. COMMITTEE OF
DAY. WILL BE NEXT SOURCES HOW DO
WE HAVE A SET. WITNESS IN. TO
HEAR IN HEARING ROOM. LOOKS LIKE
NOT SO WE HAVE SOMEBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE MISTER MINER-
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN BRING THE
PERSON ON. THE PHONE IN SUPPORT.
OF FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE. HI
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE- ANYWAYS AND
WILLIAM POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
THEIR HOME CALIFORNIA. AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PART OF
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE. THE SPELL WILL CAUSE
ANYTHING BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL ACT OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS. THE COLFAX REGULATE
DEVELOPMENT ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
COAST CAME PROVISIONS TO PROTECT
WETLANDS MINIMIZE AIR QUALITY
AND OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
ARTICLE FIVE ALSO CONTAINS A
GLARING OPTION FOR CERTAIN TYPES
OF INDUSTRIAL DEVELOPMENT
INCLUDING. OIL AND GAS WELL
THAT. VETERANS OF THIS EXCEPTION
TWENTY THE CODE THE COMMISSION A
PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW. TWENTY NEW
WELL TO DRILL FOR OIL AND GAS.
IT'LL CERTIFIED. BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION FACTORED FOUND
PROJECT WILL BE AND CAN. WITH
THE CODE ALL THE STAFF THAT
WITHOUT FOR CAN. I THE ALL RIGHT
TO BETTER. BECAUSE OF THIS I'M
SURE FOR AWHILE AFTER BECAUSE OF
ALLOW OF PROJECT MOVE FORWARD
DESPITE POTENTIAL AND HAVE OF
ROGER WETLANDS. AND SENSITIVE
HABITAT.
REQUIRING OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT TO THE COKE WAS ON
TO BE CONSIDERED IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT IT. IS CONSISTENT WITH
REGULATION OF OTHER KIDS
INVOLVED IN PROJECTS. AND WILL
STRENGTHEN THE MUCH NEEDED
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR COUNTRY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VERY CONCISE THANK YOU ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT WITH NAME AND OF. AN
AFFILIATION. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR IF WE CAN OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY TWO WILL HAVE PLACE.
I DON'T MIND SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AMY GO AHEAD GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI HI THIS IS A KEY PART
TRACK OF FOR IDENTIFICATION
PURPOSES ON THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ENVIRONMENTAL CAUCUS BUT
SPEAKING AS AN INDIVIDUAL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. MY EIGHTEEN.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. MY NAME IS
SERRA READ THANK YOU I'M OF A
MEMBER OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
CENTRAL DEMOCRATIC COMMITTEE ON
REPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. WHAT
IN FIFTY. HI JENNIFER CAMERA-
INVISIBLE CALIFORNIA GREEN TEAM
ALSO SPEAKING THE BILL CAL THREE
FIFTY THE STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
ONE FORTY THREE. THANK YOU. BY.
THIRTEEN GOOD MORNING MARKING
HIM COME WITH THE COASTAL LAND
ACTION NETWORK STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
ONE. HEY MY NAME IS TO NOT HAVE
IT RECUR I LIVE IN ORANGE LINES
OR SB ONE FORTY THREE THANK YOU
. LINE TWELVE. MY NAME IS
GWENDOLYN HAMMERING I AM A
RESIDENT OF SAN PEDRO- ALSO PART
OF THE DEMOCRATIC CLUB AND LYFT
CONCIERGE CLUB MEMBER I AM IN
SUPPORT STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE THIRTY SIX. I AM TERRY
BRADY CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY
AND I LIVE IN MORE PARK AND I AM
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU. I AM
TWENTY SIX. MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
GLORIFYING I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE I'M PART
OF THE SILVER STRAND IN MARINA
DEL REY THANK YOU. MODERATOR CAN
YOU TELL US HOW MANY PHONE LINES
YOU HAVE- WAITING TO SPEND TEN
MORE RIGHT NOW THANK YOU FOR.
LINE TWENTY FIVE. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. MY NAME IS JANE
VELEZ MITCHELL ON WITH DEFEND BY
JANA WETLANDS FROM BULLDOZING
AND I AM IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE.
THANK. ONE SIXTY SEVEN. ADRIAN
COULTER OF INDIVISIBLE VENTURA
OUR GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. LINE. FORTY EIGHT. BY
FORTY EIGHT NINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS MERRY GO TRY OUT ONE OF
THE PROJECT PLAN THAT ALSO
INCLUDES ALL RIGHT AND I AM IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA- AND THE VP OF
DEMOCRAT FOR THE PROTECTION
ANIMAL AND IF THE STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SB FORTY TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. LINE SIXTY. HI MY NAMES
ALYSSA BISCHOFF EIN IN THE COURT
OF F. B. ONE FOUR TWO THREE
AMADOR THROUGH THE BUTTONS TASK
FORCE. NINE SIXTEEN. ROBERT ROY
FUNDED- PRESIDENT OF THE BY ON A
WEAPONS INSTITUTE STRONGLY
ASSERTIVELY SUPPORT. BY. NINE BY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SUSIE I'M COMING WHY
YOU'RE VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOR
MORE LINES MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU WELL NEXT LINE FORTY FOUR.
ANY GOLMAAL- ANGELA CHAPTER OF
THE SIERRA CLUB STRONGLY SUPPORT
. LINE SEVENTY THREE. H. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS PUNIT J.
PATHAK FRIDAY WITH A CASE OF
PURPOSES I AM AN ELECTED
DELEGATE BECOME DELEGATES AT
SIXTY TWO FORMALLY NOW EIGHTY
FIFTY FIVE OUT THE CERTAIN
EXECUTIVE BOARD WITH CALCULATOR
PART PARTY AND I LIVE RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER FROM BALLARI
WEAPONS AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY SIX. THE MORNING WATER
WEALTH CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER
FOR THE THIRD FIGHTER FOUNDATION
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN. HI
GOOD MORNING DAVID KITANA WITH
SOCIAL COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION
AND- STRONG SUPPORT AT FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR APPRECIATE IT ARE WE
WILL NOT TAKE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE WILL BEGIN IN THE HEARING
ROOM. IF YOU CAN PLEASE GIVE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
TWO MINUTE COMMENTS THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL THE
EURO ON BEHALF THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE. BECAUSE
THE NECESSARY FACILITY
IMPROVEMENTS AND RECTOR FITS
THAT IMPROVE EFFICIENCIES IN
OPERATIONS SHOULD BE CONTINUED
TO BE ALLOWED UNDER THE COASTAL
DEPENDENT INDUSTRIAL USE
PROVISIONS. IN ADDITION TO
MEETING THE NEW ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTROL STANDARDS THAT MOST GAS
FACILITIES IN OUR REFINERIES
HAVE TO MEET. THEY THEY HAVE TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT
NEW EQUIPMENTS TO MEET THE
REQUIRED SAFETY STANDARDS. WE DO
NOT CONSIDER THE EXISTING FIVE
CRITERIA THAT ARE USED IT NOW TO
BE AN OVERRIDE OR A LOOPHOLE IN
FACT IS THIS BILL DOES NOT ALIGN
WITH THE BENEFITS OF THE STATE'S
EMISSION. REDUCTION AND CLIMATE
GOALS BY DELETING THE FIVE
MITIGATION PROVISIONS IN THE
CALL TO LACK FOR REFINERIES AND
PETROCHEMICALS THE BILL WOULD
IMPACT THE ABILITY. TO LOAD AND
UNLOAD LOWER CARBON PRODUCTS BY
NARROWING THE PERMITTING L.
BLOODY. IN THESE THESE FACILITY
ARE THERE FOR A PURPOSE AND
THEY'VE BEEN THERE FOR DECADES
AND THAT'S BECAUSE REFINERIES
ARE CLOSE TO- TERMINALS AND OIL
AND GAS FACILITIES ARE CLOSE TO
WHERE YOU WANT LEADERS. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE EXISTING LAW ON
THE FIVE CRITERIA ARE
SUFFICIENT. A PATH TO GO AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE THE-
THANK YOU NEXT MONTH. JERRY
MEMBER SEAN WELL IN TIME FROM
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION TO ADD
WHAT MISTER DARO SHARED WITH YOU
ALL IN RELATIONSHIP TO
OPPOSITION- THE ANALYSIS
INDICATES THAT THE BILL INTENDS
TO OFFSET OUR RELIANCE ON FOSSIL
BASED FUELS UNFORTUNATELY- THE
BILL DOES NOTHING TO OFFSET
RELIANCE OR DEMAND FOR FOSSIL
FUELS. CALIFORNIA IS EXTREMELY
RELIANT ON FOSSIL BASED FUELS
AND WE WILL BE FOR DECADES TO
COME- IN STATE OIL NATURAL GAS
PRODUCERS OPERATE IN THE COASTAL
ZONE UNDER THE STRICTEST LAWS
RULES AND REGULATIONS ON THE
PLANET WHILE PROVIDING THE
AFFORDABLE ENERGY CALIFORNIANS
SO BADLY NEED EVERY BARREL OF
CRUDE OIL NOT PRODUCED IN
CALIFORNIA MUST BE PRODUCED
OVERSEAS BY BULLDOZING THE
AMAZON RAINFOREST IN ECUADOR.
NONE OF THE PRODUCERS OVERSEAS
ARE SUBJECT TO THE HIGHEST IN
THE WORLD CLIMATE MITIGATION
STANDARDS CALIFORNIA PRODUCERS
ARE SUBJECT TO. WE ALL KNOW THAT
THE CLIMATE CRISIS IS A GLOBAL
PROBLEM AND NOT A CALIFORNIA
ONLY PROBLEM BY CURBING COASTAL
CRUDE PRODUCTION YOUR INVITING
MORE SUPERTANKERS INTO OUR PORTS
THIS NOT ONLY EXACERBATES THE
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS BUT AS HIGH
LEVELS OF TOXIC POLLUTION. TO
THE LA BASIN FROM TANKER
EMISSIONS- CHIPS ARE ONE OF THE
HIGHEST POLLUTERS IN THE LA
BASIN ACCORDING. TO THE SOUTH
COAST AQ ANDY IF ONE TANKER HAS
A MISHAP. THE SPELLING OF UP TO
ONE MILLION BARRELS OF CRUDE ON
TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BEACHES
WOULD BE CATASTROPHIC. FOR THE
COASTAL ENVIRONMENT AND THE
LOCAL ECONOMIES THAT RELY SO
HEAVILY ON TOURISM AND
RECREATION. AS LONG AS
CALIFORNIA USED TO DEMAND ALMOST
TWO MILLION BARRELS OF CRUDE OIL
EVERY SINGLE DAY. THAT ENERGY
SHOULD COME FROM CALIFORNIA
PRODUCERS PAYING HIGH WAGES TO
CALIFORNIA WORKERS PLEASE DO NOT
OUTSOURCE OUR ENERGY NEEDS TO
COUNTRIES THAT DO NOT SHARE OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL VALUES CULTURAL
VALUES OR HUMAN RIGHTS STANDARDS. SEVERAL RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
KNOW ABOUT. THANK YOU RESTAURANT
TIME- WILL TAKE WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
ADD ON IN OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE HI MISTER VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE MONACAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL LINING A REMARKS WITH
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS WE ARE. IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SIR ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM. MODERATOR IF WE CAN OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES-
AND COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE WE'LL TAKE
THOSE COLORS NOW. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. WE
HAVE THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
COULD UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION TO THE DYESS IS THERE
ANY MEMBERS WISHING WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL- IS THERE ANY
COMMENTARY. COMMENTS YES SIR.
CAN I JUST ASK WHILE. I'D LIKE
FOR FROM SWANTON EXPAND ON ONE
THING THAT HE SAID OF THE STAND
THE ROOM- YOU'RE A Q. M. D.
COMMENT REGARDING- THE TANKER
POLLUTION AIR POLLUTION YEAH I'M
NOT SURE THAT MOST OF US HAVE A
AND UNDERSTANDING OF THAT WHAT
IT WHAT CAN YOU EXPAND ON
THEY'LL ABOUT IT WAS A TWENTY
NINETEEN STUDY THAT THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT PUT OUT AND ESTIMATED
THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE NEXT
YEAR. COURTSHIPS WOULD BE THE
HIGHEST- SACHSEN KNOCKS
POLLUTERS IN THE LA BASIN. AND
THOSE ARE THE SHIP TO BRING THE
OIL INTO THE COUNTRY IT'S BOTH
SUPERTANKERS AND ALSO CARGO
VESSELS OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND I BOUGHT. YES SIR
YEAH. COMMENTS ON JUST JUST
GENERALLY YOU KNOW I SERVED ON
THE COAST COMMISSION AND- AS
MANY OF YOU I CHAIR ENERGY AND-
CALIFORNIA'S DEFINITELY WORKING
VERY HARD TO MOVE IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION TO. BECOME COMPLETELY-
LESS RELIANT ON FOSSIL FUELS.
AND TO CREATE AN ENERGY SOURCE
THAT IS COMPLETELY SUSTAINABLE I
THINK THAT'S- A VERY IMPORTANT
THING THE KID CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO DO ONE WHEN I FIRST ARRIVED
TO THE SENATE. I STARTED SELECT
COMMITTEE ON ACHIEVING
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
AND THAT'S ALSO A VERY IMPORTANT
GOAL. THAT CALIFORNIA FIND A WAY
TO DERIVE ALL ITS ENERGY NEEDS-
LOCALLY FROM THE STATE. WHATEVER
OUR ENERGY DEMANDS ARE IF WE
CAN- ARRIVE THEM ENTIRELY FROM
WITHIN OUR OWN STATE THAT WILL
HELP TO BUILD. AN ECONOMY THOSE
ARE THERE ARE SMART WAYS TO
REINVEST ARKEMA ECONOMY TO BUILD
WEALTH IN OUR STATE. CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN REALLY GOOD ABOUT DOING
THAT THAT'S WHY WE'RE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
AND WE CAN TAKE WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE. AS A STATE AND AS THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE STATE DEVELOP
A STRATEGY. FOR POWER IN OUR
STATE. AND AFFORDABILITY. BUT
ALSO. IN A WAY THAT COMBATS
CLIMATE CHANGE THAT REDUCES OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT. AND SO WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE WORK IN IN THAT IN
THAT DIRECTION AND THERE IS A
LOT OF THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
BALANCE RIGHT RESPECT FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. RESPECT FOR
PEOPLE'S POCKETBOOKS. AND ALSO
RESPECT FOR OF OUR ECONOMY WHICH
NEEDS TO CREATE. JOBS TO PRODUCE
WEALTH AND BE A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE CAN ACHIEVE THE AMERICAN
DREAM AND THAT'S OFTEN A VERY
DIFFICULT THING TO DO. ONE OF
THE INTERESTING THINGS ABOUT OUR
STATE'S HISTORY. IS THAT
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE- WHO IS TO
CALIFORNIA'S FAMOUS FOR HAVING
PLACES LIKE LA BREA TAR PITS.
AND FAMOUS FOR REGULAR- THE YOU
KNOW THESE OIL WHAT THEY CALL
THESE TAR BALLS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPEARING IN CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE OCEAN NATURALLY FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS AND THAT'S
JUST NATURAL SEEPAGE OF WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S ALWAYS ALWAYS HAD
IN ABUNDANCE OF PUT OF OIL.
BELOW THE GROUND THAT AT SOME
POINT IN SOME POINTS JUST BEGINS
TO JUST COME UP NATURALLY AND
NATURALLY CONTAMINATE THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND IT'S YOU KNOW
IT'S SOMEHOW OILS ALWAYS BEEN A
SOURCE OF DESTRUCTION BECAUSE
WHEREVER YOU GO AND THE CARPETS
YOU HAVE- FOSSILIZED ANIMALS
SYSTEM FELL INTO THESE TARPS
THOUSANDS OF YEARS AGO AND
THEY'RE STILL PRESERVE. AND IT'S
JUST A- PART OF THE REGULAR
ENVIRONMENT AND YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT OIL EXTRACTION
HAS DONE. IS ACTUALLY REDUCED
THOSE NATURAL EMISSIONS IN THOSE
NATURAL SPILLS INTO THE FIREMAN
BY EXTRACTING OF COURSE. THE I'M
NOT ARGUING THAT IT'S GOOD FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT BY NO MEANS AND
- IN TERMS OF AIR QUALITY WHAT
IT DOES IT'S VERY DAMAGING. BUT
IN THE INTERIM CALIFORNIA HAS A
OIL ADDICTION. AND RIGHT NOW IN
MY DISTRICT THE COST OF
PETROLEUM IS THROUGH THE ROOF
THE COST OF GAS IS THROUGH THE
ROOF- WHERE WERE SEEN THAT IN
INTERNATIONAL STRUGGLE
STRUGGLES. THAT THERE ARE
COUNTRIES THAT WE ARE AS
TAXPAYERS ARE FUNDING OPPOSITION
TO IN THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THAT ARE MAKING IN- ARE ARMING
THEMSELVES. OR OFTENTIMES
FUNDING TERROR TERRORISM THROUGH
WHAT WE PAY FOR AT THE PUMP AND
I ALWAYS ASK PEOPLE WHERE WOULD
YOU RATHER SOURCE YOUR PETROLEUM
CALIFORNIA CREEK CALIFORNIA JOBS
OR FROM SAUDI ARABIA OR RUSSIA.
OR OR ARE COUNTRIES THAT ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO- CONFLICT AND TO
A THREAT TO THE UNITED STATES IN
ALMOST EVERY TIME PEOPLE SAY
CALIFORNIA I'D RATHER BUY
CALIFORNIA OIL IF- IF I'M GONNA
AND I'D RATHER I'D RATHER NOT
HAVE TO BUY OR- AND I'D RATHER
PRICES CHEAPER BUT- THAT WOULD
BE MY FIRST CHOICE. AND I THINK
WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO BALANCE
THAT DEMAND AS WE TRANSITION OUT
OF PETROLEUM AS WE MOVE. TO THE
CLEANERS SOURCES WE NEED TO.
CONVINCE CALIFORNIANS THAT WE
CAN DO IT IN A WAY THAT DOES
THAT THAT THAT. THEY SHOULD
SUPPORT. THEY SHOULD SUPPORT
CLEANING THE ENVIRONMENT IS
GOING TO CREATE JOBS. AND IT'S
NOT GONNA AFFECT YOUR POCKETBOOK
TOO MUCH ANNA AND I THINK THIS
IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO WORK ON AS A AS A
LEADERSHIP. TO PUSH THOSE
PROJECTS ARE GET GOING TO GET US
TO CLEANING THE ENVIRONMENT
REDUCING AIR EMISSIONS BUT AT
THE SAME TIME NOT. MAKE PEOPLE
REVOLT AGAINST OUR GOVERNMENT
AND SAY YOU KNOW I'M NOT GOING
TO PAY FIVE SIX SEVEN DOLLARS AT
THE GAS PUMP. AND YOU KNOW WHY.
I DON'T SUPPORT FRACKING BUT I
SUPPORT REGULATING IT IF IT'S
NOT GOING TO HURT THE
ENVIRONMENT. IF THEY CAN PROVE
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT THEY SHOULD DO IT IF
IT HAS A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
WHERE WE SHOULDN'T DO IT. AND IF
WE CAN EXTRACT OIL WITHOUT
AFFECTING THE ENVIRONMENT. I
THINK WE SHOULD DO IT FROM
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE THE
ENVIRONMENT IN THE WORLD IS THE
ENVIRONMENT AND- AND I THINK IN
CALIFORNIA WE CAN DO BETTER. AND
I THINK WE YOU KNOW OTHERS A
REASON WHY OF PETROLEUM IS
LISTED AS A CAUSE FOR THE
PENNANT USE BECAUSE IN MANY
CASES IT'S LOCATED ALONG BECAUSE
- OR ALONG THE COASTAL ZONE. AND
YOU CAN'T- YOU KEPT- EXTRACT
SOMETHING FROM AN AREA. IF YOU
CAN ENTER THAT AREA AND YOU I
MEAN IT'S AN ALL RIGHT ALL ALL
OUT MAN AND THE COASTAL
COMMISSION I WAS ON THE COAST
COMMISSION WHEN WE TOLD THE NAVY
YOU CAN'T YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING TO AVOID RUNNING
OVER WALES AND THEY CHALLENGED
US. IN IN- IN COURT SAYING YOU
CANNOT TELL THE MILITARY HOW TO
PROTECT THE COUNTRY AND CLOSE
THE COMMISSION WON THAT BATTLE.
I KNOW THE COASTAL COMMISSION
HAS- AS DOING A PHENOMENAL
PHENOMENAL JOB OF PROTECTING THE
COASTLINE. THEY HAVE VERY VERY
STRICT. RULES IN TERMS F HOW
WHO CAN- SITE THERE DEVELOP
THEIR WORK THERE IT'S A- YOU
HAVE TO SHOW OF ALMOST NO.
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT TO REALLY
GET AUTHORIZED. BY THE CLOSE
COMMISSION AND GO GET A COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT THING TO DO AND IT'S
MORE DIFFICULT. TO EXTRACT OIL
IN THE COASTAL ZONE COLONEL IN
CALIFORNIA THAN ANY OTHER PLACE.
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE COASTAL
ZONE IN THEIR- AND THEIR
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT THE
COASTLINE. AND I THINK IF- THAT
RESOURCE CAN STILL BE FOUND
FOUND THERE GIVEN WHAT I'VE SEEN
IN TERMS OF RECENT EVENTS IN THE
WORLD IN THE- IN THE IMPACT ON
GAS I MEAN THIS THIS BILL. COULD
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
I KNOW BEFORE. OF WHAT WE'VE
DONE HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE HAS
HAD AN IMPACT ON GAS PRICES. AND
IT WENT ANYTHING THAT'S- AFFECT
A LEGALLY THAT ANY BILL THAT
PASSES AFFECTS OF SUPPLY AND
DEMAND HAS HAS A NATURAL EFFECT
ON. INCREASING COSTS AND I THINK
RIGHT NOW IS THE WRONG TIME. TO
LAUNCH THIS CAMPAIGN ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE ARE EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCING THE HIGHEST- OIL
COSTS. IN IN THE- IN OUR IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY. AND I THINK WE
SHOULD BE SENSITIVE TO THAT. AND
WORK TO- YOU KNOW. PROVIDE
PEOPLE WITH THE WITH THE FUEL
THEY NEED BUT ALSO A MOVE IN A
DIRECTION WHERE WE CAN WE CAN-
CONTINUE OUR STATES GAINES ON ON
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT SO- I THINK THIS IS
A VERY NOBLE EFFORT AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO AT LEAST DRAW
ATTENTION TO THIS AND SAY LOOK
OUR THEIR SHOES WERE WEEKEND
REGULATE THE OIL INDUSTRY
BETTER. ALONG THE COASTAL ZONE-
I THINK THERE ARE AND I THINK WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THOSE BUT ON ALL
ALL OUT BAN I JUST CAN'T SUPPORT
I THINK IT. IT'LL PUT- OUR STATE
AT A DISADVANTAGE TO PROVIDE A
VERY IMPORTANT COMMODITY AT THIS
TIME. IN HISTORY. ARE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND I AND I
I'LL JUST BE LAYING OFF THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU SERVICE SO WE
HAVE A MOTION- MISTER CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE SURE AND MAY
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE- THE
REMARKS MADE A IN MY CLOTHES. AT
THIS BILL IS NOT AN ALL OUT BAN
ON OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION IN THE
COASTAL ZONE- DESPITE- MANY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO LIVE NEAR
THESE SITES IN. AND WISH THAT WE
COULD JUST WAVE THE WAND AND BE
DONE WITH THIS- THIS KIND OF-
THIS KIND OF EXTRACTIVE. ECONOMY
AND SENSITIVE HABITATS THE BILL
DOESN'T DO THAT- THE BILL
ACTUALLY SPECIFICALLY LOOK ON
PAGE FORTY ANALYSIS THE BILL
AUTHORIZES THE PERMITTING. OF
NEW WORK EXPANDED OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT. IF IT IS FOUND TO
BE CONSISTENT. WITH APPLICABLE
PROVISIONS OF THE COASTAL ACT
THE FACT IS UNDER CURRENT LAW.
OIL AND GAS HAVE BEEN GETTING A
FREE PASS IN THE COASTAL ZONE.
THAT INDUSTRIAL USE IN THE
COASTAL DEPENDENT AREAS THAT
COASTAL DEPENDENT INDUSTRIES HAS
TIED THE HANDS OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. AS DECIDED THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN EXAMPLE WHERE.
IT WAS INCONSISTENT THE COASTAL
ACT. THEY FOUND. A OIL AND GAS
DRILLING PUZZLE AND YET THEY
COULDN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE OF THIS LOOPHOLE IN
CURRENT LAW. SO THIS BILL DOES
NOT CLOSE THESE FACILITIES IT
MERELY REQUIRES THEM TO MEET THE-SAME STANDARDS THAT A HOTEL. OR
HOUSE OR ANY OTHER COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT WOULD HAVE TO MEET
AND NOT SOME SPECIAL STANDARD.
SO WITH THAT YOU KNOW I WOULD
SAY AT LEAST WE SHOULD HAVE THE
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA PLAYING BY THE RULES
THAT EVERYONE ELSE IS SUBJECT
TO- ENDS AT BEST. WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING TOWARDS THE FUTURE- AND
IN A PLACE THAT WERE NOT RELIANT
ON THIS KIND OF EXTRACTION. THE
SUPPOSITION THOUGH THAT THIS
WOULD SOMEHOW IMPACT ENERGY
PRICES IN ANY WAY WHATSOEVER
BILL LIES IN UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW GLOBAL OIL MARKETS WORK. OF
THE WAR IN RUSSIA IS WHAT'S
DRIVING WILL PRICE INCREASES IT
HAS NOTHING TO DO. WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATION WHATSOEVER THE IMPACT
OF THIS PRODUCTION MARKET AND
SPECIFICALLY THESE COASTAL
DEPENDENT USES WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY. DOES NOT AFFECT
GLOBAL SUPPLY AT A SCALE THAT IS
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO WHAT WE SEE.
FROM ALL THE OTHER RESOURCE
CONFLICTS SO IT'S A VERY EASY
TARGET RIGHT NOW FOR FOLKS TO
COME OUT AND SAY. SEE TOO MANY
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHY THE PRICES
ARE SO HIGH. THAT'S NOT WHY WE
HAVE SIX DOLLAR GAS IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S BECAUSE WE'RE
DEPENDENT. ON OPEC AND
DICTATORS. ALL ACROSS THE WORLD
FROM SUPPLYING THIS USE AND
NOTHING IN CALIFORNIA CAN SOLVE
THAT SO I WOULD HOPE THAT WE
COULD SEE. THE FOREST. AND NOT
JUST A FEW TREES HERE- AND MAKE-
IN INVOLVED DECISION ABOUT WHAT
WE DO- IN OUR WITH OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
WITH THAT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
STERN. MICHIGAN'S ON KEY PLEASE
STATE THE MOTION FORCED BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM TO SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE STERN STERN ALRIGHT
JONES JONES NO ALLEN. ALLEN ALL
RIGHT EGGMAN GROVE HERTZBERG
HUESO. LAYERED LAYERED I'D LOAN
IT HAS. OKAY THE MEASURE THREE
VOTES WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS TERRILL
AIRED IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE HERE
AND ARE YOU READY YES I'M READY
GREAT ITEM SIX IS FIRST SB NINE
SIXTY THREE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ON A PRESENT FROM HERE.
ARE YOU SAID A VERY ADMIRABLE
PRECEDENT THAT POINT- THE SENATE
BILL NINE SIXTY THREE WALL-
UPDATE THE STATUTORY FINDING AND
FUNDING PRIORITIES OF THE MUSEUM
GRANT PROGRAM THAT'S OPERATED BY
THE- CALIFORNIA CULTURAL AND
HISTORIC AND DAMAGE. THAT
ENDOWMENT WAS ESTABLISHED BY
BILL IN TWO THOUSAND THREE IT
WAS UP. HAVE. THERE WE GO EUROPE
IT GOT TURNED OFF WHILE I WAS
THERE ARE SOME HE HE DOES A
SENATOR ATKINS EVENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ATKINS DID TO TWENTY
THIRTEEN UPDATE IN THIS BILL
UPDATES OF THE PRIORITIES OF
SPECIFICALLY THESE CHANGES OR
PRIORITIZE FUNDING PROJECTS AND
PROGRAMS THAT SERVED UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES PROTECT AT RISK
CULTURAL AND HISTORIC RESOURCES
SUPPORT ETHICAL STEWARDSHIP OF
SENSITIVE ART AND ARTIFACTS AND
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT
CRITICAL CALIFORNIA ISSUES SUCH
AS CLIMATE CHANGE IN RACIAL
EQUITY. ARM IT'LL ENSURE THAT
THE MUSEUM GRANT PROGRAMS EQUIP
TO SUPPORT MUSEUMS FOCUS ON
COLLABORATION AND ENGAGEMENT
WITH LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OUR JENNIFER CABALLERO FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUMS AND COULD TREES LEE OF
THE SAN DIEGO NATURAL HISTORY
MUSEUM- I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
LAYERED WE'LL HEAR FROM THEIR
LEAD WITNESSES NOW. I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE ANY IN THE ROOM NO
I THINK WE'LL TURN THE LIGHTS.
THE MODERATOR WHICH PLEASE QUEUE
UP LEAD WITNESSES FOR SB NINE
SIXTY THREE. I BELIEVE IT'S MISS
CABALLERO AND EARNESTLY. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
AND JENNIFER CAVALEIRO. THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUM SPONSOR OF
SB NINE SIXTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
THE OVER TWO HUNDRED
INSTITUTIONS AND OVER ONE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS OF
THE ASSOCIATION. I EXTEND MY
GRATITUDE TO SENATOR LAERTES
AUTHORSHIP. THE UPDATES TO THE
MUSEUM GRANT PROGRAMS FUNDING
PRIORITIES PROPOSED BY SENATE
BILL NINE SIXTY THREE ALONG WITH
AN ACCOMPANYING BUDGET REQUEST
WILL BUILD ON THE CURRENT AND
LONGTIME PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND USE THE
TIME TO INVEST IS NOW. TWENTY
YEARS AFTER THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL ENDOWMENT AND THE
MUSEUM GRANT PROGRAM. AND COMING
ON THE HEELS OF THE MUSEUM
SECTORS NEARLY EIGHTEEN MONTHS
OF PANDEMIC CLOSURES. SB NINE
SIXTY THREE ENSURES THAT THE
GRANT PROGRAM ALIGNS WITH THE
STATE'S PRIORITIES TO
COLLABORATE WITH HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. PROTECT
CULTURAL ASSETS FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE AND OTHER THREATS ENHANCE
ACCESSIBILITY TO ALL AND- STUART
. ARTIFACT HI AND PROGRAMS. BY
THE FUNDS WILL HELP CULTIVATE A
MORE JUST AND SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE. MUSEUMS ARE IMPORTANT
COMMUNITY CENTERS THA NEED AND
DESERVE THE STATE'S ONGOING
INVESTMENT SUPPORT. I WANT TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPECIFICALLY THANK YOU CHAIR
STERN AND SENATOR LATER. AS WELL
AS COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR
ALAN MALONE AND HERTZBERG WE ARE
CONSISTENTLY STRONG SUPPORT OF
FUNDING FOR CCTV AND INDIAN
GRANT PROGRAM. THANK YOU I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH M. FOR THE
NEXT WITNESS. HI WITH THE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M PATRICE LEE AND
I THIRDS AT THE SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF DEVELOPMENT AND GRANTS FOR
THE SAN DIEGO NATURAL HISTORY
MUSEUM IN BALBOA PARK ALSO KNOWN
AS THE NET. I ALSO SERVE AS A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MEDIUM. MY INSTITUTION SERVES
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE EACH YEAR OKAY VARMAN FOR
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND INCLUDED THE FINAL
RESEARCH THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE BAJA
CALIFORNIA PENINSULA. WE'RE AS
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HOW
CALIFORNIANS CAN RESPOND IT IS
ONE OF THE PRIORITIES IDENTIFIED
IN SB NINE SIXTY THREE. FOR
EXAMPLE WE RECENTLY OPENED
CALIFORNIA BLOOMING A
PHOTOGRAPHIC EXHIBITION THAT
EXPLORES HOW OUR FAITH
STRAORDINARIO WILDFIRES. ARE
BEING IMPACTED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE. CALIBRATE CALIFORNIA
BIODIVERSITY WHILE MAKING THE
CONNECTION ACTIONS WE MUST TAKE
TO PROTECT IT. BUT NOT ALSO
PARTNERED WITH THE CLIMATE
SCIENCE ALLIANCE THE AWKWARD
YOUTH AND ADULT PROGRAMMING
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TODAY TO YOU FOR THE
STATE NEED FOR CREATING THAT.
CULTURAL AND DOWN IT AND- URGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT AND
EXPAND PROGRAMS LIKE THE FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB NINE SIXTY THREE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- CONCLUDING THE LEAD
WITNESSES WILL TURN THE GENERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- IN THE
HEARING ROOM. IN HEARING ROOM
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING AND I'M
HERE VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT SB
NINE SIX THREE ON BEHALF OF MY
CLIENTS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUMS CAL
NONPROFITS AND THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES THE OAKLAND ZOO. IN
OAKLAND MUSEUM OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT SEEING NON LET'S TURN
TO THE LINES- MISTER MODERATE
WOULD YOU CARE IF ANYONE WISHING
JUST FINE GENERAL SUPPORT FOR.
SB NINE SIXTY THREE. AND THIS
WILL BE JUST NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION. YOU CAN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY SIX
GLAD. GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
KILEY SHALL BE CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES THEY SHOULD BOTH BE
SCIENCE CENTER AND THE DISCOVERY
KEEP MUSEUM IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT. WE DO HAVE ONE
OTHER LINE ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER. WILL
OPEN NINE THIRTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. ALL RIGHT FOR THE AMERICAN
MUSEUM OF CERAMIC ART IN POMONA
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT. LINE SIXTEEN.
ROBERT ROY VANDERCOOK IN SUPPORT
OF FROM LOS ANGELES FOR MUSEUMS
AND MUSEUMS THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER LINES INTO MISTER
CHAIRMAN OKAY VERY GOOD- WILL
THEN TURN TO OPPOSITION WE DON'T
HAVE ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION
HERE ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM
THOUGH WHICH AND TESTIFY SEEING
NONE WE TURN TO THE LINES PLEASE
ANYONE WISHING JUST FINE
OPPOSITION. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. VERY GOOD THANK YOU- WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK THEN TO THE DIS- I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AT THE OUTSET I THINK
YOU'RE GIVEN THE ENERGY AND
INVESTMENT WE'RE MAKING IN THESE
PROGRAMS- IN IN THE OVERALL- IN
THE OVERALL FUND- AND NOW AN
UPDATE TO THE IN DOWN ACT I
THINK IS A- WISE AND TIMELY AND
I APPRECIATE SOME OF THE UPDATES
ESPECIALLY IN THE FINDINGS TO
NOTING- SOME OF THE CARETAKING
INTERPRETATION ROLE THAT MUSEUMS
PROVIDE. ESPECIALLY FROM FOR THE
RESOURCES COMMITTEE I THINK YOU
KNOW THAT INTERPRETIVE COMPONENT
IS REALLY WHAT MAKES EDUCATION
STICK HELPS BRING UP THE NEXT
GENERATION SO THE APPROPRIATE
TIME OF LOVE TO BE ADDED ON TO
THE MEASURE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP HERE. I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION OR ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS A MOTION
FROM SENATOR HERTZBERG NO OTHER
COMMENTS LATER CLOSE. PROTECT
THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS IS A CLOSE
I THANK EVERYBODY FOR A
TESTIFYING IN THEIR SUPPORT AND
I WOULD ASTRONOMICAL VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH- SO THE MOTION
IS. TO PASS. BUT FIRST RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE AND
APPROPRIATIONS CHIEF CONSULTANTS
CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM SIX S.
B. NINE SIXTY THREE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED WITH HER FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS STERN HI STERN
I'D JONES ALLEN ALLEN ALL RIGHT
EGGMAN GROVE HERTZBERG I DON'T
THINK I WANT TO PURCHASE I DON'T
THINK THAT I WAS A REAL LIFE TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN WHEN I FIRST
ENTER OUR BUT I'LL DOUBLE IT UP
AND- HI. HERTZBERG AYE HUESO
LAYERED I LEARNED I. DON'T THREE
OF THE MEASURE AS FOR OUR EYES
ONE STRONG. ONE MEDIUM- WE WILL
MOVE ON TIME EXACTLY I WAS DOING
SOMETHING THAT I ACTUALLY LIKE
TO COOPER- AND LET LET LET'S
JUST LET'S JUST GO THE END WOULD
THAT BE HAVE FOR FULL YEAH. WHO
WE DISCUSS THAT. PRINCIPLE
CALLED. WE'VE NOW WE'VE BROKEN
THE SYSTEM NOW IN THE SENATE
FROM THIS UNRULY. AND WAY TOO
EXPERIENCED BUNCH- SO LET'S KEEP
LET'S STAY ON A ROLL HERE CENTER
THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP GOING YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARRESTER
CHAIR OF THIS IS- SENATE THE
BILL NINE SEVENTY SEVEN I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIRED THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORK WITH ME IN MY
OFFICE ON THIS BILL. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS WHICH
MAKE THE BILL BETTER OF THIS
BILL IS SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO
MY SENATE BILL THREE TWO TWO
FROM LAST YEAR THAT PASSED THIS
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY. OF THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THE
DIFFERENCES CHIEF AMONG THEM
WOULD BE HOUSING THIS PROJECT.
AT THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD WHICH WAS NOT THE
SUGGESTION OF LAST YEAR. IN ARM.
RECENT YEARS THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS FOR
ACTIVITIES TO BENEFIT HABITAT
AND WILDLIFE ON PRIVATE LANDS
WITH THE WATERFOWL HABITAT
PROGRAM THE WINNER RICE HABITAT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. AND THE
NESTING BIRD HABITAT PROGRAM A
SENATE BILL NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
WILL ADD TO THAT PORTFOLIO BY
ESTABLISHING OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION RANCHING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM UNDER THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. THAT HAS
SIGNIFICANT EXPERIENCE MANAGING
SIMILAR PROGRAMS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS. CALIFORNIA'S
GRASSLANDS MORE RAPIDLY
DETERIORATING AS TWENTY THOUSAND
ACRES OF RANGELANDS ARE LOST
EVERY YEAR OF THIS PROGRAM WILL
POINT OUT WILL AWARD GRANTS TO
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES TO ADMINISTER
PLAN AND IMPLEMENT LOCAL
PROGRAMS THAT ENHANCE OR RESTORE
CALIFORNIA'S NON PUBLIC
RANGELANDS GRAZING LANDS. AND
GRASSLANDS- THIS BILL ENJOYS
WIDESPREAD SUPPORT FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES AND
RANCHERS HAS NO OPPOSITION WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
PULLING OUT OVER AS ON BEHALF OF
AUDUBON CALIFORNIA. AND DANICA
MARKET GUARD ON BEHALF OF MARKET
GUARD FAMILY GRASS FED L. L. C.
I RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL TURN
LEAD SUPPORT WITH MRS- I BELIEVE
WE HAVE- FIRSTLY TO BOTH ON THE
COASTLINE SO MODERATE WOULD YOU
PLEASE TURN LEAD SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS I'M THE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT CONFIRMATION WRENCHING
PROGRAM NINETEEN SEVENTY WE HAVE
LOST ONE IN EVERY FOUR BIRDS
THREE BILLION BIRDS. PRIMETIME
BIRDS HAVE BEEN DECLINING THE
MOST BY MORE THAN 50% DUE MOSTLY
TO HAVE DEADLOCKED AND CLIMATE-CHANGE. THE FEDERAL MENTIONED WE
LOSE ABOUT TWENTY FIVE TO MAKE A
GRASSROOTS IN CALIFORNIA EVERY
YEAR. ONLY THEN WILL IT FAMILY
RIGHTEOUS BETTER HABITAT. FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL. BENEFITS LIKE
KERN TO CONSTRUCTION. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COME DECLINE
PROVIDING INCENTIVES TO KEEP
BRANCHES WRENCHING AND MANAGE
THEIR LAND BEN HOW TO THAT THAT
WILL BE EITHER CONNECTED
SERVICES. THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
GOING TO TAKE IT'S LIKE ALL THE
PHONE TO CONTINUE PARTNERING
WITH A BRANCH OF BY SUPPORT THEM
WITH. AND ASSISTANCE SO THEY CAN
IMPLEMENT PRACTICES AND
MAINTAINING THAT HABITAT THE
PROPOSAL HELP CAPTURE CARBON.
AND WATER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR OF IS. WHAT NOTE TO A- MARKET
GUARD. HI MY NAME IS DONNA
GOTTEN MARQUEE GUARD AND- MY
FAMILY AND I- WE ARE- RANCH ON
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND ACRES OF
COASTAL GRASSLANDS AND THE NOW
MOUNT MORAN AND SAN MATTEO
COUNTY. AND WE PRODUCE GRASS FED
BEEF ON THOSE RANGELAND BUT I
ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT WE PRODUCE
THOUSANDS OF SPECIES AND PROVIDE
A HEALTHY HABITAT FOR. I SO MUCH
BIRD LIFE PLANT LIFE AND THAT
THE CAT OF THE BUG AND BELOW
THAT THE SOIL AND THESE PROGRAMS
ARE SO IMPORTANT FOR I THINK
CONTINUE TO THROUGH THE
CONSERVATION WORK THAT WE ARE
DEALING. I IN ORDER TO THE WORDS
USED GRASSLANDS ARE BECAUSE
THESE GRASSLANDS EVOLVED WITH
GRAZING ANIMALS AND WE NEED TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MOVE THEM
THROUGH THE LANDSCAPE REDUCE THE
FUEL LOWERED- TO BE MORE
RESILIENT TO- THESE MEGA FIRES
THAT WE ARE SEEING. AND ALSO TO
HELP DRAW DOWN CARBON I DO
PARTNER WITH A LOT OF GREAT
SCIENCE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
MONITOR AND INCREASE IN
BIODIVERSITY AND INCREASE IN
THESE. FEES ARE CONCERNED LIKE
THE GRASSHOPPER SPARROW ON THE
GRABBED LAND AND INCREASE IN
SOIL ORGANIC CARBON YEAR AFTER
YEAR AND WE'RE SEEING THESE NOW. THE- OR THE GRASSLANDS TO
START CARD. EVEN MORE THAN FOR A
BECAUSE THERE MORE REDUCE. TO
WILD- IF ARE GREAT SO WE CAN
DRAW DOWN HER WE PROVIDE HIGH.
FOR BIRD. ARE AND WE CAN BE HE
CALLED WHERE- GRASS FED. AND WE
WITH OTHER BONTA WELL ALL OF OUR
ARE CERTIFIED BY AUDUBON ON
WHICH SHOWS THAT THEY ARE ALL
PART OF REGENERATIVE GRAZING
PRACTICES. THAT IMPROVE SOIL
CARBON AND HABITAT AND
BIODIVERSITY LIKE I MENTIONED
RIGHT STRONGLY URGE YOU FROM THE
RANCHING COMMUNITY AND
CALIFORNIA TO COURT THIS BILL SO
THAT WE CAN DO EVEN BETTER I OUR
JOB- MAINTAINING THE HABITAT
FOR. SO MUCH ALIKE AND DIVERT TO
BE AND THAT LIVED. WITH IN THE
PLAN. THANK VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TO IN AND YOUR YOUR KNOWLEDGE ON
THE SUBJECT- WHAT WE'LL TRY TO
GENERAL SUPPORT WITNESSES NOW IN
THE MEASURE. DO WE HAVE ANY IN
THE ROOM HEARING ROOM IS SEEN
NINE WHAT LET'S TRY TO LINE'S
MODERATOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY AND GENERAL SUPPORT FOR
SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY TWO GO AHEAD. LINE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
ABIGAIL MILE ON BEHALF OF. THE
PROJECT BY TRAFFIC COUNTY COURT%
. THANK YOU NEXT FOR. RIGHT.
EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING IN
DELFINO REPRESENTING DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY WITH THE
AMENDMENT TO THE BILL WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT. LINE SEVENTY
TWO. OUT OF THE HOUSE THE VIRAL
DEFENSE FUND IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME VERY GOOD THANK YOU-
TURNED OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE
ANY REGISTERED ON FILE ANY IN
THE HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE THE
STREAMLINED THIS MODERATOR
ANYONE WITNESS TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION. SB NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN. SPEAKING OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THE THEN ZERO THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN IN
Q. VERY GOOD- EXHAUSTING ALL
TESTIMONY WILL TURN BACK TO- THE
DIET I'LL JUST SAY AT THE OUTSET
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK
WITH US AND WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND SPECIAL THANKS
STAFF- FOR DIGGING IN- THE
DETAILS HERE AND REALLY TRYING
TO GET A SOLID PURPOSE STATEMENT
BEHIND THE PROGRAM AND SOME
FLEXIBILITY FOR W. C. B.
IMPLEMENTATION SOME THE OTHER
ELEMENTS OF THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE- THE AMENDMENTS ARE WORKING
WITH US ON THIS AND I THINK IT
THE BILL THE BILL CAN. HOPEFULLY
NOT JUST PRODUCE CARBON IN AND
HABITAT BENEFITS BUT BUT REALLY
ALSO GIVE YOU KNOW ENTREPRENEURS
LIKE YOUR YOUR LEAD WITNESS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MARKET
THEMSELVES- NOTICES AUDUBON
CERTIFIED BUT IN THEORY- YOU
KNOW CERTIFIED IN SOME WAY BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
HOPEFULLY CONSUMERS RESPOND TO
THAT KIND OF- MARKET LEADERSHIP
AS WELL WHEN THEY'RE WHEN
THEY'RE MAKING- GROCERY STORE
DECISIONS SO- THANKS FOR THANKS
FOR THAT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS I RECKON YES AND
CEREMONY I WOULD WITH THE BILL
OKAY. THAT'S A MOTOR CENTER
EGGMAN. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS SEEING NONE. EARLIER
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE I THANK THE
CHAIR FOR HIS COMMENTS THANK THE
WITNESSES- FOR PARTICIPATING AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL.
VERY GOOD SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHIEF CONSULT WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM SEVEN
S. B. NINE SEVEN SEVEN THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN ALL RIGHT STERN ALL RIGHT
JONES. ALLEN ALLEN ALL RIGHT
EGGMAN. THEY WENT ON A GROVE
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG RIGHT
HUESO. HUESO ON A LAYERED. AYE
LITTERED AYE LIMÓN. SIX OKAY.
THAT MEASURE SIX VOTES WILL EVEN
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT
UP WE HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB ELEVEN SIXTY SEVEN FROM
SENATOR ALAN YOU CAN BE PRESENT
AT YOUR CONVENIENCE. THANK YOU
IS YOUR MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
FIRST START BY THINKING DENNIS-
YOUR GREAT STAFF HERE MISTER
CHAIR- THAT. I WANNA- JUST THINK
YOU KNOW. ALL THE WORK WE'VE
DONE TOGETHER AS WE PREPARE FOR
SOME EXCITING ANNOUNCEMENTS THAT
ARE TO COME IN THIS SPACE THAT
I'LL TALK ABOUT THE SECOND. SO
THIS BILL IS A PLACEHOLDER BILL
THAT WILL ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENACT THE STATUTORY CHANGES
NECESSARY TO SET CALIFORNIA ON
ITS COURSE. TO MEET THE GOALS
OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
THIRTY BY THIRTY INITIATIVE-
PARTICULARLY FOCUSING ON
STRATEGIC LAND ACQUISITIONS.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT I'VE
BEEN INTERESTED IN SINCE I.
FIRST DECIDED TO RUN FOR THIS
POSITION. I AS YOU KNOW THE
THIRTY BY THIRTY MISCHIEF
PLEDGES TO CONSERVE. 30% OF OUR
STATE'S LANDS. AND COASTAL
WATERS BY THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY
ENSURING THE RICH BIODIVERSITY
AND VITALITY F CALIFORNIA'S
VAST FORESTS AND COASTLINES AND
GRASSLANDS DESERT'S MORE. WE
PROTECT IT FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO ENJOY AND EXPLORE
AND OF COURSE IT'S PART OF A
GLOBAL PUSH. IN THIS SPACE I
SAID THIS IS THE WEEK WHEN-
CALIFORNIA WILL RELEASE THE
FINAL VERSION OF THE PATHWAYS TO
THIRTY BY THIRTY STRATEGIC PLAN
WHICH WILL OUTLINE THE ACTIONS
THAT ARE STATE AGENCIES AND
THEIR PARTNERS WILL TAKE TO
IMPLEMENT OUR AMBITIOUS
CONSERVATION GOALS ALONGSIDE
INNOVATIVE MEASURES TO. BUILD
CLIMATE RESILIENCY. SO STATE
PARKS HAS AN ESTABLISHED
PROCEDURE FOR ACQUIRING NEW LAND
PARCELS FOR CONSERVATION
RECREATION- BUT- PROGRAM DELAYS
HAVE RESULTED IN MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIGH PRIORITY
ACQUISITIONS IN AN OVERALL TREND
OF GROWTH GROWTH STAGNATION.
WITH THE LAST SIGNIFICANT
ACQUISITION BE MADE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN QUITE FRANKLY MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO EACH OF
YOU ABOUT HOW WE CAN.
REINVIGORATE PARKS I THINK
THEY'VE NEVER QUITE RECOVERED
FROM- THE SCANDAL THEY DEALT
WITH WHEN I FIRST CAME INTO THE
LEGISLATURE OVER- HOARDING
FINDS. I YOU KNOW- AND THEY'VE
NEVER EITHER THIS IS AN AGENCY
THAT PROVIDES INCREDIBLE SERVICE
TO OUR POPULATION- PEOPLE USING
THE PARKS MORE THAN EVER NOW
THAN EVER BEFORE THEY'RE THEY'RE
SO OVER UTILIZED- AND YET- I SEE
THAT A LACK OF AMBITION OVER
THERE WHEN IT COMES TO. BUDGET
REQUEST STICKING UP FOR
THEMSELVES ASKING FOR WHAT THEY
NEED AND A NEW LAND ACQUISITIONS
SUCH THAT WORK. YOU KNOW THIS DO
LEGISLATURE USED TO BUY PARK
LAND ALL THE TIME. IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT I'VE SEEN HAPPEN
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE. I AND
WE'VE BEEN RUNNING EVERYTHING
THROUGH THE CONSERVANCY'S WHICH
IS A GOOD THING BUT- BUT OUR
STATE PARKS REALLY. OUGHT TO BE
PLAYING A ROLE IN THE SPACE TO
AS THEY ALWAYS HAVE
HISTORICALLY. I AND SO YOU KNOW
IF CALIFORNIA IS TO ACCOMPLISH
ITS CONSERVATION RESTORATION
GOALS IN JUST EIGHT MORE YEARS
AS- AS THE TWENTY THIRTY.
DEADLINE APPROACHES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TO BE REPAIRED
TO HELP ENHANCE THE ACQUISITION
TOOLS. AVAILABLE TO STATE PARKS
AND ENTITIES LIKE IT TO AND ALSO
I THINK WE NEED TO HELP OUR
INSTITUTIONS OUR STATE AGENCIES
TO. KEEP PACE WITH THE
EXPANSIONS ON THE HORIZON SO.
THIS BILL WILL SERVE AS A
VEHICLE TO IDENTIFY THE
STATUTORY HURDLES AND STATE
PARKS AND OTHERS EXPERIENCE IN
ACQUIRING NEW PROPERTIES AND
ENACT RECOMMENDATIONS.
HIGHLIGHTED BY THE PATHWAYS A
THIRTY BY THIRTY STRATEGIC PLAN
THAT. IS GOING TO BE IS ABOUT TO
BE ANNOUNCED. AS THE STEWARDS OF
MANY OF CALIFORNIANS- PARKLANDS
AND PROTECTED HABITATS ENTITIES
LIKE STATE PARKS AND WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. MUST BE WELL
EQUIPPED TO QUICKLY MOBILIZE AND
PREPARE FOR THE GROWING
JURISDICTIONS. CALIFORNIA'S
LEADING THE NATION IN ITS
EFFORTS TO FORTIFY AND PRESERVE.
BUT ON A TO RESOURCES. I WITH
THIS BILL WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS A STRONG PARTNER
IN ACHIEVING OUR THIRTY BY
THIRTY CALLS ON BEHALF OF
GENERATIONS. OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
WILL COME AFTER US AND BENEFIT
FROM. THE ACTIONS THAT WE TAKE
NOW IS WE SET ASIDE MORE PARK
LAND. MORE LAND FOR THEM TO
ENJOY IT FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT TO
GROW AND THRIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
AND- RECOGNIZING THAT THIS IS IN
THE- EVOLVING SPACE WITH. A LOT
OF. LEADERSHIP COMING NOT JUST
FROM THE GOVERNOR BUT- BUT ALSO
THE PRESENT UNITED STATES WITH
THE RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT- FOR
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL ON THIS FRONT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT HAVE. THIS
VEHICLE MOVING AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON
INFECTED LIKE TO. SIGN ON ONCE
WE DO DEVELOPMENTS IN JOINTLY
YOUR PRINCIPAL SOME WAY BE A
PART OF THIS WITH YOU-
APPRECIATE YOU GET AHEAD OF IT I
THINK STATE ARKS IS A CRITICAL
ROLE TO PLAY WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LEAD TO PORT WITNESSES SEEING
THAT. THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
SO. IF THERE'S ANYONE WAS
TESTIFYING GENERAL SUPPORT HERE.
YOU'RE WELCOME AT THIS TIME BUT
SEEING NINE. MODERATOR CAN YOU
TURN THE PHONE LINES. ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I
DON'T THINK WE WILL HAVE A
MOMENT AND- WELCOME TO OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO I COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD-
ANYONE IN THE HEARING WAS
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE. SEEING NINE HERE
TURMERIC ETERNAL LINES ANYONE
WISHING TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION WITH. THE EURO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN OF ONE THEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT THIS
TIME OKAY VERY GO BRING BACK TO
DYSON EARLIER. HE IT I'M GONNA
MOVE THE BILL IN A IN A MOMENT
BUT I'D LIKE TO GIVEN THE
OPENING STATEMENT I'D LIKE TO
OFFER SOME COMMENTS BECAUSE-
THIS LEGISLATURE THROUGH
DIFFERENT BONDS. ASCERTAINED
BECAUSE MOST OF THE SPENDING ON
PARKS ACQUISITION WAS GOING TO
RURAL AREAS AND URBAN AREAS WERE
BIG TO COLLECTED THAT BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS HAVE BEEN SPENT ON
PARKS AND THEY'VE BEEN GUIDED TO
URBAN AREAS WHETHER IT'S FORMER
RAIL LINES WHETHER IT'S FORMER
RIVERS. ARE I MEAN FORMERLY NOT
DEVELOPED RIVERLANDS LIKE AROUND
THE L. A. RIVER AND OTHER PLACES
AND SO THERE'S BEEN BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BUT- LEGISLATURE. IN THE
VARIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS REALLY
DECIDED IT SHOULD BE GUIDED TO
LOCAL PARKS AND-
DISPROPORTIONATE NEGLECTED URBAN
AREAS SHOULD ACTUALLY BE DONE.
IN THEIR WORST SIGNIFICANT
REFORMS BUT ONE OF THE GREATEST
ONCE CAME FROM THE LEGISLATURE
IN CONCERT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION A SIXTY MILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR CASH. INFUSION
THROUGH THE OTHER TRANSPORTATION
BONDWHICH WAS THE LARGEST CASH
IN FEW CONFUSION TO PARKS IN A
GENERATION AND THAT HAS LED TO
FILLING POSITIONS IT IS LEAD TO
MORE PLANTS IT HAS LED TO THE-
TO THE- SETTING UP THE DIFFERENT
ACQUISITIONS IN ADDITION TO
JUST- YOU COULDN'T PAY. BOB BY
CREDIT CARD OR PLASTIC AT ANY
PARK IT THAT'S UP TO OVER A
HUNDRED YOU COULDN'T BE PROMOTED
INTO LEADERSHIP AND LOST YOUR
BATCH LAW ENFORCEMENT WHICH WAS
REALLY DISADVANTAGING WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR AT THAT WAS
DRAMATICALLY CHANGED. ARM DOES
LEGISLATURE DIDN'T ALLOW FOR
LOCAL PARTNERS FOR PARKS THEY
HAD TO BE AUTHORIZED AND THERE
WAS A BILL THAT REALLY ALLOWED-
MANY MORE AND THE- STATE PARKS
DIDN'T EVEN ACCOUNT TO BUY
INDIVIDUAL PARK IF YOU WANT TO
KNOW HOW TO HELP AN INDIVIDUAL
PARK YOU COULDN'T DO IT. THEY
KEPT BY REGION SO THERE WERE
MASSIVE REFORMS THAT WERE MADE.
AFTER THAT THAT WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT. AND I
THINK. I'M WAY MEETING AS THE
AUTHOR IS WITH SOME BAY BREATH
BECAUSE- THE THIRTY BY THIRTY
HAS BEEN A VAGUE THING US FOR.
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS VAGUE
THE FIRST REPORT WAS VAGUE THERE
THERE WERE NOT SPECIFICS AND I
KNOW I OFFERED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION A LADDER WITH
EVERY SPECIFIC PROJECT I THINK
THAT WOULD EXIST IN MY SENATE
DISTRICT THAT THEY SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING. THAT INCLUDES
FOURTEEN THOUSAND ACRES OF LAND
BY THE DIABLO CANYON NUCLEAR
PLANT AND MANY PLACES WHERE
WHERE THIS IS AVAILABLE SO I
REALLY I LOOK FORWARD TO. TO
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BECAUSE I
LOOK FORWARD TO THEM GIVING US
SOME SPECIFICITY THAT WE CAN
MOVE ON BOTH BUDGETARY EARLY AND
WITH THE GUTS OF YOUR BILL WHICH
WILL COME IN AND IN THAT SPIRIT
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
OKAY THAT'S A MOTOR CENTER
LITTLETON CENTER HERTZBERG. I
CAN'T BELIEVE SENATOR LISTENING.
TO THE CBO. THANK YOU. I CAN'T
PERCENT AROUND SIT NEXT TO THE
FORMER SECRETARY OF RESOURCES.
M. ALMOST THE ENTIRE TIME YOU
SERVE IN GOVERNMENT HE WAS THE
SECRETARY ADMINISTRATION TELLING
ME HE DID NOTHING WHEN HE WAS
THERE AND THE JOB. IS PRETTY
GUTSY OF YOU BUT THAT'S WHAT HE
DID A GREAT JOB IN. BRINGING IT
BACK AND I GOT TO TELL YOU
THERE'S BEEN A BUNCH OF OTHER
ENDEAVORS WITH RESPECT TO PARK
AND THE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE
AND WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE WE
SPENT TIME WITH JORDAN INSTANT
THE IF THE- AT THE CONSERVANCY
IS THAT. WE'VE SPENT TONS OF
MONEY ON PARKS THERE. VIA GO
SECURELY ACT IN OTHERS. BUT WE
DON'T HAVE A PER MONEY. SO THEY
GIVE TRAFFIC TICKETS OUT AT VERY
EXPENSIVE RATES TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE OPERATIONAL MONEY. AND SO
THE WHAT THE GENIUS OF WHAT OUR
SENDER SECRETARY LATER TALKED
ABOUT HIS THEY WERE BASICALLY
WHAT WAS GOING ON INTERNALLY IT
WASN'T SO MUCH BECAUSE OF RUTH
AND WHAT HAPPENS DEPARTMENT. BUT
THEY WERE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THEY COULD STILL CREATE.
LEVELS OF PARKS PARTICULARLY IN
CITIES WHERE AS THE CHAIR
PRESENTED THE OTHER DAY YOU KNOW
YOU'VE GOT BECAUSE- BECAUSE YOU
HAD- WHAT WAS A QUICK QUIMBY
FUNDS. AND QUIMBY FUNDS IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY PRODUCE LIKE
YOU KNOW A THOUSAND ACRES OF
PARK VERSUS WHAT WAS HAPPENING
EAST LOS ANGELES WHERE THEY HAD
AN ACRE PARKS BECAUSE OF THE
HISTORICAL DEVELOPMENT THE CITY.
AND QUIMBY FUNDS REQUIRED
DEVELOPMENT CITIES OR WILL
DISAPPEAR DESPARD PROBLEMS AND
SO WHAT SENT BUT WITH SECRETARY
LAIRD WAS ELEGANTLY DOING IN
QUITE BRILLIANTLY TOGETHER IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LEGISLATURE
DURING THOSE YEARS. WAS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE COULD
CREATE MORE INNER CITY PARKS AND
TRANSFER THE OPERATIONAL
EXPENSES TO. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
I THINK THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE LARGER DYNAMIC. IN IN WHAT'S
GOING ON LOOK IT'S IMPORTANT I
AGREE AND SUPPORT YOUR BILL I
LIKE IT A LOT. IS WHEN HE WILL
DELIVER HIS CONTEXT THERE AND
DEFEND OUR COLLEAGUE FOR HIS
EXTRAORDINARY WORK. BECAUSE HE
DID A FANTASTIC JOB. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG- ALLOW YOU TO
REACT IN YOUR CLOTHES- DO WE
HAVE TO- THE ANY MORE COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS A WEEK
WE'RE GOOD THERE THE ONLY LAST
THING I JUST SEE PRELOAD TO
ACTION THAT DOESN'T DOESN'T EVEN
DEPEND ON THE ADMINISTRATION- IN
OUR BUDGET PROCESS WHICH WILL
RUN IN PARALLEL TO THIS MEASURE
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE
PUTTING FORWARD THE SENATE'S
PLAN ON BIODIVERSITY- ON NATURAL
WORKING LANDS- AND LOOKING TO
POTENTIALLY BUILD AND EXPAND ON
THE MULTI BENEFIT NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS. A PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO I THINK
THERE WILL BE A IMPORTANT
INTERPLAY THERE AS WELL WITH
FLEXIBLE KIND OF RESOURCES THAT
CAN GET TO OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE AS WELL AS WELL
EXISTENCE FROM I'M EXCITED THAT
WE'RE TAKING SOME OWNERSHIP
HERE. AND I'LL BE SUPPORT
MEASURE ANALYZE A QUOTE I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S SUPPORT A
GREAT DEAL AND I AND I DO WANT
TO- ECHO MY COLLEAGUES- PRAISE
AND LOVE FOR OUR FORMER
SECRETARY IN OUR COLLEAGUE HERE-
AND JUST TO CLARIFY THAT MY- I.
AGREE THAT THAT THE FOCUS ON
LOCAL URBAN PARKS IS IMPORTANT
AND IT IS IT CONTINUES TO BE
IMPORTANT. I ALSO THINK. THAT
OUR EXISTING PARK
INFRASTRUCTURE. I NEED A LOT
MORE TLC I THINK THE MAINTENANCE
OPERATIONS OUR OUR OUR OUR
CONTINUE TO BE A PROBLEM I'VE I
AM AN AVID. VISITOR OF OUR STATE
PARKS AND I'M ALWAYS A LITTLE
SAD WHEN THEY- WHEN THEY LACK
BASIC AMENITIES- WHEN THE VIDEOS
IN THE VISITOR CENTER FROM THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES- WHEN. I YOU
KNOW WHAT WHEN IT WHEN IT WHEN I
SEE HOW MUCH NEED THERE IS HOW
MUCH USED AREAS INCLUDING FROM
URBAN COMMUNITIES LET ME JUST
STATE. AS GREAT AS URBAN PARKS
ARE PEOPLE STILL WANT TO GET OUT
OF THE CITY INTO WILDERNESS. AND
THE DEMOCRATIZATION OF OUR STATE
PARKS HAS BEEN EXTRAORDINARY IN
MY OWN LIFETIME IMAGES TO SEE
I'VE BEEN HIKING CINEMA COMMANDS
FOR EXAMPLE SINCE I WAS LITTLE
KID. IN TO SEE. THE AMOUNT OF
UUSINTA PANDA STATE PARK FOR
EXAMPLE OVER YOU SINCE I WAS A
LITTLE KID TO NOW. AND THE. FROM
LOS ANGELES ARE GOING UP IN THE
STATE PARKS BRINGING FAMILIES.
BRING DIVERSITY TO OUR STATE
PARKS- IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO ALSO BE TAKING YOUR ACCOUNT
AS WE ALSO PUSH FOR URBAN PARK
LAND. AND SO THAT'S YOU KNOW
THAT AIM BY THE WAY. I'M A LOT
OF THAT WILDLAND. THERE IS A
RACE AGAINST DEVELOPMENT LANDING
IN AND AROUND OUR URBAN AREAS
THE WILDERNESS LAND THAT'S NEAR
OUR URBAN AREAS IN THE BAY AREA
AND LOS ANGELES. ARE GET IS
GETTING INCREASINGLY EXPENSIVE.
I THINK A LOT OF TIMES STATE
PARK JUST KIND OF HOLD WITH
RAISES HANDS IT SAYS THERE'S NO
WAY WE CAN A FOR A FOR THIS. IT
IT IT SAYS IT IS SILOS THEM
DEEPER AND DEEPER INTO THIS
WORLD APPROACH AS OPPOSED TO AN
URBAN APPROACH. AND I JUST WNNA
MAKE SURE WE'RE TAKING THAT
WHATEVER BEARS WE CAN. TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR THEM TO PURCHASE
AND MAINTAIN. AND PROTECT AND
PRESERVE- ALL TYPES OF PARKLAND
INCLUDING I'M M. MY PERSONAL
INTEREST IS REALLY DEEPLY IN.
WILDERNESS AREAS ADJACENT URBAN
AREA. ARE BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S AN AREA WHERE THERE'S SO
MUCH NEED- AND SO MUCH- A DEMAND
WHEN IT COMES TO OUTDOOR
RECREATION OPPORTUNITIES WITH
OUR PUBLIC THAT DID THAT THE YES
APPRECIATE THE URBAN PARKS BUT
ALSO WANT A LITTLE TASTE OF
WILDERNESS. THEY CAN DRIVE TO.
GET BACK TO THEIR HOMES IN TIME
FOR DINNER AND SO- ANYWAY I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS I
CERTAINLY. WANT TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH WITH THE SENATORS AND I AND
I DO WANT TO APPLY TO THINK- MY
COLLEAGUE FOR IT FOR ALL HIS
HARD WORK IN THIS SPACE OVER HIS
CAREER- WHICH REALLY HAS BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY AND- APPRECIATE
HIS MOTION AND- RESPECT
FASHIONABLE. VERY GOOD THE
MOTION IS. TO PASS THE- TO PASS
THE FIRST RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHIEF CONSULTANTS CALDERON FILE
ITEM EIGHT S. B. ELEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN STERN ALRIGHT JONES ALAN
HI ALAN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN. EGGMAN
I GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO HUESO ARE A LAYERED
LAYERED I LIVE. LIMÓN HI. VERY
GOOD THAT MEASURE SEVEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS- LAST ITEM UP
HERE SB NINE I MEAN SORRY ITEM
NINE SB TWELVE OH FIVE CENTER
ALLEN. WITH THE MESSAGE CARE-
ONCE AGAIN WE START BY THINKING
DENNIS FOR HIS THOUGHTFUL WORK
HE'S A- THESE ARE- ARE VERY ON
TASMANIAN DEVIL IN A POSITIVE
WAY- YEAH AND IT TELLS ME DANGER
THERE YOU GO. I CAN HIT I'VE
BEEN OF IT IN A VERY POSITIVE
WAY I'M VERY HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHICH I
ACTUALLY THINK HELP THE BILL-
QUITE A BIT I WISH WE THOUGHT OF
SOME OF THE THINGS HE ADDED AND
CHANGE IS ALREADYA
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTING MOST
ASPECTS OF LIFE IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE GOT DEVASTATING FIRES IN
DESTRUCTIVE MUDSLIDES FLOODS.
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS ALL SORTS OF
THINGS THAT WE TALK ABOUT QUITE
A BIT IN THIS COMMITTEE. OF THE
STATE'S WATERSHEDS OF COURSE
HAVE NOT ESCAPED THE EFFECTS OF
RISING TEMPERATURES AND
CHANGING. PRECIPITATION
PATTERNS. ART SO WHEN THE
STATE'S WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD AND IS ASKED TO ISSUE A
NEW PERMIT TO APPROPRIATE WATER
. FROM A WATERSHED. OF THE
BOARD'S PRACTICES BANNED TO
ESTIMATE. THE STREAM FLOW. FROM
EITHER HISTORICAL STREAM GAUGE
RECORDS OR FROM MODELS THAT
CONSIDER HISTORICAL DATA AND
OTHER FACTORS. OPPERMAN
APPLICANTS ARE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT TO THE STATE WATER BOARD
QUOTE SUFFICIENT INFORMATION TO
DEMONSTRATE A REASONABLE
LIKELIHOOD THAT AN APPROPRIATE
WATER IS AVAILABLE FOR THE
PROPOSED APPROPRIATION. HOWEVER
APPLICANTS ARE NOT GIVEN
GUIDANCE OR STANDARDIZED
METHODOLOGY TO ACCOUNT FOR
CHANGES IN WATER SUPPLY. IN
AVAILABILITY DUE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE IN FACT CLIMATE LAW-
CALIFORNIA'S LAW IS SILENT ON
THE ISSUE- AND NOT AS IN SPITE
OF ALL OF THE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW ARE HAPPENING. I'M USING
HISTORICAL DATA TO. I PREDICT
WATER AVAILABILITY IS A GRAND
MISTAKE CHANGING RAINFALL
PATTERNS AND PROJECTIONS A
DWINDLING SNOWPACK AND MADE ALL
THE MORE URGENT THAT WE CONSIDER
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS. ON
CALIFORNIA'S HYDROLOGY BEFORE
DETERMINING IF A RIVER STREAM
HAS SUFFICIENT WATER TO ISSUE A
NEW PERMIT. SO THIS BILL CALLS
ON THE STATE WATER BOARD. TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS THAT
ESTABLISH A METHODOLOGY TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL HAVE ON
WATERSHED RESOURCES THIS WILL
ENSURE A MORE ACCURATE
ASSESSMENT OF WATER AVAILABILITY
IS CALIFORNIA FACES AN ERA. OF
WARMER AND DRIER- AND CHANGING
CONDITIONS AND HERE WITH ME TO
SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL HELP ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ARE PROFESSOR JENNIFER
HARDER FROM MCGEORGE. SCHOOL OF
LAW RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
ALSO DR PETER GLICK WHOSE
PRESIDENT EMERITUS OF THE
PACIFIC INSTITUTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WOODARD DR WITH IS
HARDER IN THE HEARING ROOM NOW
WILL COME TO THE HEARING ROOM
FIRST THEN OR SHE IS HERE IN THE
AREA OF- WHO IT. HOWEVER YOU'D
LIKE TO PROCEED. A PROFESSOR DR-
SEPARADA DR GLICK WELCOME THANK
YOU THE WITNESSES OF DISCUSSED
AT ALL I'M VERY WELL PLEASE
PROCESS SENATORS THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION TO PRESENT ORAL
AND WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED
SOME WRITTEN TESTIMONY FOR YOU
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. RO TWELVE OH
FIVE I'M DOCTOR PETER GLICK
COMMA CLIMATE AND WATER
SCIENTIST WHILE WORKING FOR FOUR
DECADES ON CALIFORNIA WATER AND
CLIMATE ISSUES I'VE PREVIOUSLY
SERVED ON THE PUBLIC ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FOR THE- ON THESE
ISSUES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
CHANGE. TAKEN WITH VISOR
COMMITTEE I'M A MEMBER OF THE U.
S. NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
I HAVE SERVED ON A RANGE OF
COMMITTEESASSOCIATED WITH.
THESE ISSUES. THE PURPOSE OF THE
PROPOSED BILL IS VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND SIMPLE WHEN
IT'S NEEDED. THAT IS TO GIVE THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD THE EXPLICIT ABILITY. TO
CONSIDER THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE INCLUDING DROUGHTS
EXTREME EVENTS LAND USE CHANGES
GROUNDWATER SURFACE WATER
INTERACTIONS. IN THEIR WORK TO
DETERMINE WATER AVAILABILITY
WHEN ISSUING AND ADMINISTERING
WATER PERMITS AND WATER
LICENSES. SUCH EVALUATIONS ARE
LONG OVERDUE AND I'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE JUST THREE
JUSTIFICATIONS FOR THE BILL. THE
FIRST IS THE SCIENCE IS VERY
CLEAR CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL
IT'S CAUSED BY HUMANS IT'S
ALREADY AFFECTING CALIFORNIA
WATER RESOURCES AND IT'S NOT
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE WAY WE DEAL
WITH THOSE WATER RESOURCES. TO
OUR EXISTING WATER MANAGEMENT
RULES AND INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING
THE ISSUANCE AND ADMINISTRATION
OF WATER RIGHTS DO NOT
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE IN PLANNING AND
MANAGEMENT. AND THIRD THE
PROPOSED CHANGES ARE LONG
OVERDUE AND ALIGN WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS AGAIN SOME FROM
LITERALLY DECADES AGO FROM
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING WATER
UTILITIES IN THE WATER
MANAGEMENT COMMUNITY EACH OF
THESE POINTS THESE THREE POINTS
ARE EXPLAINED. IN MORE DETAIL IN
MY WRITTEN TESTIMONY LET ME
SIMPLY CLOSE WITH ONE QUOTE FROM
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS AGO. FROM
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION FOR THE
ADVANCEMENT OF SCIENCE IN A BOOK
CALLED CLIMATE CHANGE AND U. S.
WATER RESOURCES THEY SAID QUOTE.
GOVERNMENTS AT ALL LEVELS SHOULD
REEVALUATE LEGAL TECHNICAL AND
ECONOMIC PROCEDURES FOR MANAGING
WATER RESOURCES IN THE LIGHT OF
CLIMATE CHANGES THAT ARE HIGHLY
LIKELY END OF QUOTE. THIRTY TWO
YEARS AGO. THIS BILL IS A STEP
IN THAT DIRECTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR
GO AGAIN FOR YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY AS WELL- NOW WELCOME
TRANSFER HERDER. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT SB TWELVE OH FIVE.
I'M JENNIFER HARDER A PROFESSOR
AT MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW HERE
IN SACRAMENTO WHERE I TEACH
WATER RESOURCES LAW.
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW- PUBLISHER
WATER LOCKED HIS BOOK.
PREVIOUSLY I WAS AN ATTORNEY AND
A PARTNER TO SACRAMENTO WATER
LAW FIRM. I'M SPEAKING TO YOU AS
A MEMBER OF A GROUP OF SEVEN
LINE POLICY EXPERTS WHO RECENTLY
DEVELOPED A SUITE OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REFORM
CALIFORNIA WATER LAW TO MEET THE
CHALLENGES OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE RELEASED IN FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SB TWELVE OH FIVE IS
CONSISTENT WITH OUR UNANIMOUS
RECOMMENDATIONSARE GROUPS
RECOGNIZE THE TRUTH OF WHAT THE
COMMITTEE HASTALKED ABOUT TODAY
AND DOCTOR CLICKS TESTIMONY THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE ISN'T IMMINENT
CRISIS FOR ALL WATER USERS
WHETHER THEY'RE WATER SUPPLIERS
ARE LANDOWNERS OR BUSINESS. OR
THE ENVIRONMENT. SO CONSISTENT
WITH OUR RECOMMENDATION SB
TWELVE OH FIVE WOULD PROVIDE THE
STATE WATER BOARD WITH CLEAR
DIRECTION AS TO LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY. BUT WOULD ALSO
APPROPRIATELY ALLOW THE BOARD TO
EXERCISE ITS EXPERT TECHNICAL
AND POLICY JUDGMENT REGARDING
THE DETAILS OF THE REGULATION.
TO ONE OF THE KEY STRENGTHS OF
S. B. TWELVE OH FIVE. IS THAT
UPDATING WATER AVAILABILITY TO
INTEGRATE CLIMATE CHANGE WILL BE
EQUALLY BENEFICIAL FOR ALL WATER
STAKEHOLDERS OUR GROUP OF ONE
POLICY EXPERTS UNANIMOUSLY
AGREED THAT THIS IS A CRITICAL
STEP FOR THE STATE TO DEVELOP AN
ACCURATE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
AMOUNT OF WATER AVAILABLE FOR
ALL USERS. IT'S A WIN FOR
EVERYBODY I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH FASTER I
WILL TURN ON THE GENERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- TO HAVE
ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM WHICH
WHICH AND TESTIFY. YEAH WELCOME
SO WHAT YOU CAN DO IS JUST- WAIT
IN QUEUE AND THEN STEP RIGHT UP
TO THE MIKE AT YOUR CONVENIENCE
WELCOME. JONAS MINTON THE
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE IS
PLEASED TO JOIN OVER THIRTY
ORGANIZATIONS FROM THE OREGON
BORDER TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
MISTER MINTON. WELCOME MY NAME
IS CHARLES CROWDER HI LIVE. AT
THE INTERSECTION OF ARDEN WAY
AND WATER OFTEN ALONG AMERICAN
RIVER. I MOVED THERE IN NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WHEN MY FATHER
RETIRED FROM THE AIRFORCE. I
GREW UP IN THE PHILIPPINES. I'VE
BEEN GOING TO THE AMERICAN RIVER
SINCE I WAS ELEVEN. I USED TO
SKI. LOTS OF WATER ON THERE I
JUMPED OFF THE MANY SACRAMENTO
THE MINIATURE SACRAMENTO STATE-BRIDGE. WHEN IT WAS ELEVEN FEET
I WOULD DROP DOWN TO THE BOTTOM
TOUCH OFF AND PUMP UP. I HAVE A
BRAND NEW KAYAK BOAT ABOUT THREE
YEARS AGO I'M NOT GONNA TAKE IT
OUT BECAUSE IT WOULD BE SCRAPE
ON THE ROCKS OF THE RIVER. I
REMEMBER FONDLY WHEN MY FATHER
WOULD COME HOME WITH SALMON HE
CAUGHT IN THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
AND WE WOULD SMOKE MADE OUR
BACKYARD. MY SON LOVE SMOKE
SALMON THERE ARE NO SALMON IN
THE RIVER. MY CHILDHOOD FRIENDS
AND I USED TO FISH ALL THE TIME
IN THE AMERICAN RIVER I'M
WAITING FOR THEM TO COME BACK.
IT'S NOT COMING BACK I
UNDERSTAND IT'S VERY SAD. WHERE
IS NO WATER AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM ALL THESE EXPERTS
AND I. HOPE THAT YOU'RE
LISTENING TO THEM. THEY'RE VERY
WISE THEY HAVE ALL THE DEGREES
UNDERSTOOD BUT SOMEONE WHO LIVES
IN THE WATER IN THE AMERICAN
RIVER THERE IS NOT IN ITS NOT
COMING BACK IN SO CLIMATE CHANGE
IS REAL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ARMS ME GREATLY THANK
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATED AND YOU
KNOW I INDULGED THE COMMON JUST
BECAUSE YOUR LIVED EXPERIENCES
IS MAKES IT ALL TANGIBLE. THIS
IS JUST GENERAL SUPPORT
TESTIMONY BUT- BUT REALLY THANK
YOU FOR LETTING US SOME. SOME
INSIGHT INTO. WHAT RIVERS DO AND
WHAT WATER IS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S MORE THAN JUST WATER-
GENERAL SUPPORT TESTIMONY JUST
NAME- AND AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL- UNLESS YOU
JUMPED INTO THE RIVER AS A KID
YOUR DAD SMOKED SALMON WITH YOU
. THAT'S THE ONE PRECONDITION
WILL RETURN TO THE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
GENERAL SUPPORT WITNESSES NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION. TO SPEAK
OF SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO FIRST
LINE FIFTY FIVE. I THIS IS
MARTIN DOCUMENTS ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT IN YOUR SUPPORT IF
AMENDED WE APPRECIATE THE
REASONABLE AND WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE GOING FORWARD THAT
WATER AVAILABLE ANALYSIS USING
THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. LIKE. EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING KIM DELFINO REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY AND DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. WE DO HAVE A COUPLE MORE
LINES CUED UP ONE MOMENT WHAT
WOULD PROVIDE THEM THEIR LINE
NUMBERS. GOOD LIFE EIGHTY NINE.
WHAT I FIND HERE. THEY HAVE TO
CHURN SENATORS FOR THE FRANCHISE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
HAVE SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
WE APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE WITH
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONVERSATION MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT. LIKE NINETY. THIS IS JANET
PARK IN FRONT SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU AND- L. THANK YOU
. NEXT. NINE FORTY FIVE. HI THIS
IS A FRIEND A BATH WITH- TRIAL
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE SUPPORT IF AMENDED ON
THE BILL. HERE AGAIN THE MYTH
THAT OF COMPARE ALREADY THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT. NO PROBLEM I THINK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OKAY THANK
YOU- WE WILL NOW TURN TO ANY
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
IDENTIFIED IN THE ANALYSIS ANY
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHICH
DESPITE OPPOSITION SEEN NONE.
TURN TO THE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE CALL ANYONE
WHICH DESPITE OPPOSITION. TWO S.
B. TWELVE OH FIVE. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NOT LINE'S
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIRMAN. OKAY
VERY GOOD- WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DYESS- APPRECIATE THE
CENTER HUESO YEAH PLEASE HAVE
BEEN. I THINK I JUST WANNA MAKE
SOME COMMENTS ABOUT THIS BILL
LOOKING AT THE BILL AND- READING
THAT SINCE THAT. UNDERSTANDING
HOW CALIFORNIA MANAGES HIS%
RESOURCES THIS IS A BIG BILL AND
I JUST WANNA. THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING ON THIS ISSUE I'VE
I'VE BEEN SERVING ON ON A COUPLE
COMMITTEE BETWEEN MY SERVICE IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE I'VE
BEEN NOW THIS WOULD BE MY TWELVE
YEAR SERVICE TWELVE YEARS
SERVING ON. ON WATER RELATED
COMMITTEES AND I'VE SEEN A LOT
OF WORK THAT WE'VE DONE DONE
WITH GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT AND
MANAGING OUR ATER SO MANY
DIFFERENT LEVELS AND PASSING THE
WATER BOND. AT YOU KNOW WATER
PROJECTS ARE EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE
WHETHER WE'RE GOING TO BUILD.
RESERVOIRS OR CONVEYANCE OR YOU
KNOW- THAT. INJECT INTO
GROUNDWATER ALL THAT IT'S VERY
COSTLY. AND SO WE HAVE TO REALLY
FIND- NEW CREATIVE WAYS TO
MANAGE THE OF A VERY IMPORTANT
RESOURCE. FOR OUR STATE HI WHEN
I FLY HOME FROM SACRAMENTO I
OFTEN SIT ON THE SIDE. FACING
THE SIERRAS HAVE ALWAYS LIKE TO
SEE THE SNOW PACK AND I WAS LIKE
TO SEE THE LEVEL OF THE
RESERVOIRS. ONE THING I I'VE
NOTICED. IN MY RECENT MOST
RECENT FLIGHTS DUE TO WILDFIRE.
A LOT MORE OF THE SIERRA-
DOESN'T REALLY HAVE TREES TO
PROVIDE SHADE. THAT WILL PROVIDE
AT LEAST SOME PROTECTION TO THE
SNOW SLICK LAST LONGER IN THE
YEAR. AND THERE ARE ENORMOUS
SWATHS OF MOUNTAINSIDE THEY'RE
NOT EXPOSED. AND WE CAN EXPECT
THAT A LOT OF THAT THAT WATER IS
GOING TO COME DOWN THE MOUNTAIN
A LOT SOONER. THAN NORMAL AND
OFTEN TIMES WHEN IT'S NOT NEEDED
BAND AND ADVOCATE COULD BE
POTENTIALLY LOST- TO- FIRST FOR
THE BENEFITS OF AGRICULTURAL AND
HUMAN USE AND THAT IS SOMETHING
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO REALLY TAKE
A- ANOTHER LOOK AT I HOPE. THAT
THE- BUT THE WATER BOARD LEVEL
WERE WERE WERE- WE'RE TAKING
NOTE OF THAT BECAUSE IT'S GOING
TO HAVE I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE COULD HAVE NEVER
PREDICTED. A WHEN I GOT ELECTED
TWELVE YEARS AGO WE COULD HAVE
NEVER PREDICTED THAT WOULD
HAPPEN AND SO- A BILL LIKE THIS
IS GOING TO HAVE TO COME IN AND
START TO MAKE VERY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS. ABOUTHOW WE MANAGE
WATER BECAUSE I MEAN WE USED TO
HAVE SEVEN IN SAN DIEGO AND
TIJUANA RIVER. AND TO SEE THAT
IT'S NOT EVEN IT'S AT WHERE-
I'VE HEARD FROM PEOPLE AND I
NEVER SAW IT BUT BEFORE I GOT
ELECTED PEOPLE'S USED TO SAY
THAT THE AMERICAN RIVER USED TO
TURN RED. WITH ALL THE SALMON
SWIMMING UPSTREAM. AND I NEVER
GOT TO SEE THAT AND WE PROBABLY
NEVER WILL AND THAT'S AND THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE WE'RE TRYING TO
STILL. TRYING TO MANAGE THAT
RESOURCE. IN A WAY- THAT TO ME
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE IT'S A LOSING
BATTLE SO- THIS IS A BIG BILL
AND I APPRECIATE WORKING ON AND
I'M PLEASED TO SUPPORT AND BE
LIKE TO BE A- CO AUTHOR FIFTY.
FIVE FIVE KANSEN POINT. OKAY
VERY GOOD- MANY OTHERS COMMENTS
QUESTIONS- WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION AS WELL. THE MOTION FROM
SENATOR LA MON- I TOO WOULD-
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE BILL WITH THE COMMITTEE
HERE I'D I'D LOVE TO JOIN ON
WITH- WITH OUR AUTHOR HERE. AND
CO AUTHORING HIS MEASURES WELL
AND I'LL JUST SIMPLY SAY AS THE
ANALYSIS RIGHTLY POINTS OUT THAT
THE PAST WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE CHANGE IS NOT A GOOD
PREDICTOR OF THE FUTURE. SO WE
LOOK TO OUR HISTORY FOR WHAT
WATER CYCLES WILL LOOK LIKE WILL
BE WOEFULLY DECEIVED- AT AN
UNDER PLANNED AND LEFT BLIND
SIDED SO WE HAVE TO LOOK TO NEW
TOOLS- AND- NEW- NEW MODES OF
ANALYSIS AS WELL AS NEW HARDWARE
TO DO THE MEASUREMENT THAT WE
ACTUALLY NEED TO GET A SENSE OF
OUR HYDROLOGY AND REALLY MAKE.
DECISIONS THAT SET US UP FOR
SOME KIND OF SUSTAINABILITY IN
THE LONG TERM- SO WITH THAT- THE
MERGER THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED- THE FIRST AMEND AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHIEF INFO DO
YOU WANT TO SORRY DID YOU WANT
TO CLOSE APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
AND HOUSE RIVAL OKAY VERY GOOD
WELCOME THE CALL THIS IS. VERY
GOOD. CHIEF UNTIL THESE
CALDERON. FILE ITEM NINE S. B.
TWELVE OH FIVE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSES AMENDED BEFORE IS
DEMANDING RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN. STERN ALL RIGHT JONES
ALLEN AYE ALLEN ALL RIGHT
EGGMAN. EGGMAN RA GROOVE
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT HUESO. HUESO ARI
LITTERED. LITTERED ALL RIGHT
LOAN. LOAN HI. OKAY THE MEASURE
SO VOTES WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS- THAT
THAT WRAPS UP OUR FORMAL
PRESENTATIONS WILL ROLL THROUGH
THE- THE BILL'S ON CALL FOR THE
MEMBERS WHO WERE ABSENT. WHEN WE
START WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
. JUST A MOMENT. THERE YOU GO.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FILE
ITEM FOR FILE ITEM FIVE FILE
ITEM TEN. ALLEN ALLEN ALL RIGHT
GROVE LIMÓN MON HI WELL THAT IS
EIGHT BELIEVE IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBER- NEXT UP THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS S. B. ONE
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE GROWTH SB
ELEVEN IS A NO RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR- AND THE BILL
CURRENTLY HAS HOW MANY VOTES THE
BILL CURRENTLY HAS THREE FOUR
AND- FOR AGAINST OKAY ALLEN.
ALLEN NO. THE NO NO. THAT THAT
MOTION FAST MOTION FAILS- BUT AS
IN- INTO THE- THE AGREEMENT
EXACT WHEN IT FAILS WITHOUT
OBJECTION- I WOULD SEEK THAT
RECONSIDERATION BE GRANTED
THERE'S A MOTION NEED TO BE MADE
TO CONSULTANT NO WITHOUT
OBJECTION WITHOUT OBJECTION.
OKAY WITHOUT OBJECTION BE
CONSIDERATIONS GRANTED FOR THE
AUTHORS REQUEST OKAY LET'S MOVE
ON TO A FILE ITEM TWO SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE. FOURTEEN
FILE ITEM TO CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ONE EGGMAN. EGGMAN
HIGHGROVE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT HUESO. LIMON LIMÓN HI. IT HAS SIX OKAY SIX- EXAMINE
ABSENT WEEK CLOTHES THAT GROW
GROVE IS ABSENT. OKAY SHE'S NOT
COMING BACK COMING BACK OKAY
OKAY SO WE'LL WE'LL CLOSE THE
ROLE ACTUALLY SO THEN IN THAT
CASE SORRY LET'S LET'S CLOSE THE
ROLE ON- ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AS WELL. CONSENT CALENDAR IS
EIGHT ZERO OKAY. AND ON STERN
THE MODE IT IS FOR. SIX ONE OKAY
VERY GOOD SO FAR IN THREE SB
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTERS
FIVE ZERO ALAN. ALLEN ALL RIGHT
EGGMAN EGGMAN I'D GROVE LIMÓN
MON HI OKAY THAT MEASURES OUT
MOVING ON TO SB NINE SIXTY THREE
. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX FILE ITEM
SIX THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO JONES. EIGHT JONES I EGGMAN
EGGMAN HI GROVE HUESO HUESO ISLA
MOAN MOAN ALL RIGHT EIGHT ZERO
OKAY EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURES OUT
SB NINE SEVENTY SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN- THE CURRENT VOTE
IS SIX ZERO ON FILE ITEM SEVEN
JONES. ACT JONES HI GROVE LIMÓN
LIMÓN HI OKAY THAT MEASURES OUT.
SB ELEVEN SIXTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT FOLLAND CURRENT
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO JONES. JONES
NOAH GROVE. SEVEN ONE OKAY SEVEN
ONE OF MEASURES OUT AND THE
FINAL ITEM S. B. TWELVE OH FIVE
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE. CURRENT
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO ON FILE ITEM
NINE JONES. JONES ARI GROVE.
PEOPLE OKAY VERY GOOD- THAT
DOESN'T REALLY HEARING TODAY
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR A PROMPT
AND EFFICIENT HEARING THIS YEAR
THIS MEETING IS HEREBY TURNED.
OUT HERE.